[Musique]
oh
mais messieurs bonsoir cette émission
spéciale de 24,60 se poursuivre pour les
trois prochaines heures nous
continuerons évidemment de suivi
réaction au décès de l'ancien premier
ministre du québec monsieur bernard
landry qui nous a quittés aujourd'hui à
l'âge de 81 ans
mais nous allons maintenant parler des
états unis c'est vraiment une journée
historique là bas un référendum au fond
sur l'air de donald trump le démocrate
nourrissent l'espoir peut être 20 d'une
vague bleue qui leur donnerait le
contrôle de la chambre des représentants
alors que les républicains eux
conserverait le sénat ce serait une
sorte de demi victoire pour eux mais à
l'heure où on se parle il ya quelques
premiers résultats très partiels leurs
espoirs vont-ils se concrétiser ils
viennent d'arracher un premier siège au
républicain en virginie
c'est très serré pour l'instant dans les
cours à la chambre des représentants 26
démocrates sont en avance pour 1,4
républicaine des bureaux scrutin sont
encore ouverts en raison des fuseaux
horaires regarder ces files d'attentes
pour le faire en 2018 faire des heures
d'attentes pour voter sur des bulletins
parfois qui font plusieurs pages
la grande question ce soir est vraiment
référendum sur donald trump va-t-il s'en
sortir plus fort affaibli qu'est-ce que
ça annonce pour 2020 alors au cours des
trois prochaines heures nous suivons les
développements des résultats
d'aujourd'hui et ses collaborateurs sont
aux quatre coins des états unis
nous irons leur parler en direct au
cours des trois prochaines heures et en
studio et à washington
à mes côtés pour nous accompagner que ce
sens la treille à washington en studio
charles fils david john parisella karine
brémond et donald cuccioletta est à
l'écouté laurent theillet que vous
connaissez bien grand tamis de 24 mois
semble notamment des spéciales et
laurent vous avez déjà quelques-uns de
ses résultats très partiels très partiel
en effet d'abord je peux vous dire que
802 le sénateur démocrate du vermont a
été réélu c'est le cas aussi pour le
sénateur démocrate tim kaine en virginie
ailleurs il y à des luttes partout au
sénat à la chambre des représentants on
sera là pour vous dévoiler les résultats
et les analyses et tout au long de la
soirée très bien surtout qu'à 20h ce
soit il ya déjà encore de très nombreux
bureaux de vote qui ce qui ferme et on
en aura deux des résultats au cours des
prochaines minutes
c'était une campagne vous savez ça merci
voici un rappel très bref
mais des événements qui ont ou qui vont
peut-être faire la différence au cours
de cette journée historique
[Musique]
les jeunes s'offre un fourre tout
m
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
jean paul corps
je ne sais plus
[Musique]
des truites racing ends et les vacances
moi c'est quand même
[Musique]
il faut rappeler
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
oui mais les truites wade sexting et
voilà mais claire chevrier et 3 l'équipe
3 qui sera meilleur destin en bleu au
modèle canal et toinette in et que je
vois une cheminée
[Applaudissements]
alors est ce que c'est un référendum
parce qu'il est un monsieur thiam disait
déjà que dans le fond c'est peut-être
pas un référendum alors nous
correspondants sont sur le terrain que
ça l'a trahie washington va faire beau
vielles auclair à miami qui est à
surveiller la floride un état très
important bonjour bonsoir à vous deux
je commence avec vous raphaël est
transféré de ces lettres l'action se
passe parce que les premiers résultats
sont là en ce moment les yeux sont rivés
sur la course notamment du gouverneur
entre démocrates à doug hurley et le
républicain ron d santis alors qu'est ce
qu'on peut dire de cette course
maintenant cette heure ci monsieur
guillaume à une mince avance en ce
moment sur son adversaire républicain
et c'est vraiment une course qui est
surveillé de près il ya plusieurs
facteurs pour cela un juke est l'homme
qui est maire de tallahassee s'il était
élu ce soir deviendrait le premier
afro-américain gouverneur de la floride
il deviendra aussi premier gouverneur
démocrate en plusieurs décennies dans
cet état où le poste a été occupé par
des républicains et monsieur bel homme
il faut dire à faire campagne avec des
idées avec des promesses qui selon le
spectre américains sont considérés comme
étant très progressiste de l'autre côté
ron de santis lui est un proche de
donald trump
il a des idées qui sont très proches de
celles du président a alors cette course
là elle est à surveiller voyez monsieur
games est toujours en avance mais on
parle de quelques fractions de
pourcentage
je vous dis quelques autres conçu six
oreilles ici en floride
la course au sénat un démocrate devait
défendre son siège bien nelson contre
l'actuel gouverneur de la floride de
rick scott machination mène en ce moment
mais encore là c'est assez serré puis on
serait aussi quelques districts à la
chambre des représentants notamment
celui dans lequel je me trouve ici à
miami en a un autre plus au sud ce sont
des districts qui sont représentés par
les républicains mais qui en ce moment
sont le théâtre d'une avance démocrate
ça pourrait faire une différence
évidemment sur la scène nationale alors
nous on est dans un rassemblement
favorable aux démocrates les gens
commençaient à arriver et je peux vous
dire qu'à chaque fois que sur les écrans
télévision
on montre un résultat de la floride
notamment
au poste de gouverneur suit ça de près
et on riait beaucoup et je jouais ici à
washington le président semble s'il
regarde les résultats à la maison
blanche alors ils en ont le pauvre hurle
pas entendu de la journée était
tranquille oui effectivement il était
plutôt tranquille ce qui est plutôt rare
dans son cas
monsieur thiam qui a été très très actif
durant cette campagne électorale de 2000
mandat écouter l'organiser au cours des
dernières semaines
11 rassemblement dans huit états très
important pour les républicains
pour l'heure leur prêter main-forte
monsieur de chambre qui regarde cette
cette soirée électorale en compagnie de
ses amis et de sa famille à la maison
blanche ils avaient voté par
anticipation il ya de ça quelques
semaines à new york à sa résidence de
new york et monsieur thiam qui était
vraiment un élément clé dans cette
campagne rarement anne-marie at-on vu un
président autant autant s'impliquer pour
le meilleur ou pour le pire déjà on
entend des grondements du côté
républicain en disant bay peut-être que
le président aurait pu s'abstenir et
laissé plus de place aux candidats il ya
eu des sondages vous savez aux états
unis ont fait des excès de peau c'est à
dire ces sondages lorsque les gens
sortent des bureaux de scrutin pour
sonder leurs opinions sur toutes sortes
de choses qui se passe aux etats-unis et
il ya une majorité d'américains lors de
ces sondages de sortie des bureaux de
vote qui mentionnait que ces politiques
à l'égard de l'immigration qui était son
cheval de bataille au cours des
dernières semaines sont beaucoup trop
dur alors ça il y avait des gens qui
avaient commencé à lui reprocher donc
beaucoup de courses ce soir très
importante
à suivre j'en suis moi en particulier
celles en indiana
le sénateur d'honorer le sénateur
démocrate si les démocrates espèrent
pouvoir reprendre le contrôle du sénat
ce qui est loin d'être certain monsieur
dans nos lits doit absolument garder son
siège de l'indiana et le kentucky aussi
le district numéro 6 et mimiques grands
comptes et des bars ça on est en
territoire trump si les démocrates
réussissent à faire une percée dans le
district numéro six au kentucky
mais tous les espoirs sont permis pour
hu s'est bien passé le début de la
soirée par le prêtre est longue on sache
qu'en californie
il n'y a pas de majorité décisive
sur ces 23 sièges à gagner pour les
représentants passent quand on dirait qu
bleu gestion ce serait au moins pour les
représenter non pas pour l'ensemble
selon john sano par 26 26 sièges alors
voila merci question alors écoutez
madame et messieurs c'est un système
électoral très complexe que celui des
américains on a demandé à laurent de
nous faire un petit cours sans un très
bref pour vous expliquer un peu de
caisse qui est en jeu ce soir
oui très bien on dit que c'est un
référendum possiblement sûr dans notre
armée henry a en réalité monsieur drop
n'est pas sûr aucun bulletin de vote ce
soir c'est le congrès dont il est
question ce soir
voici ce que vous devez savoir pour bien
comprendre le fil de cette soirée le
voici ce fameux congrès il a deux
chambres d'un côté vous avez le sénat de
l'autre vous avez la chambre des
représentants il faut comprendre que les
sénateurs et les représentants ne sont
pas élus dans les mêmes cycles et
sénateurs sont élus pour des mandats de
six ans tandis que tous les
représentants sont élus pour des mandats
de deux ans ce que ça veut dire
concrètement c'est que ce soit ou au
fait au cours de la journée
les américains sont allés voter pour 435
représentants l'ensemble de la chambre
des représentants mais seulement 35
sénateurs 36 gouverneurs d'état et ça
c'est sans ajouter à peu près 6000
postes au niveau des législatures des
par des juges ou encore des shérifs on
s'intéresse moins à ça ici on va rester
au niveau de la chambre des
représentants des sénateurs est un peu
des gouvernants pour certaines luttes
série ce soir je vous parlais du sénat
lorsque je dis qu'il ya 35 sièges qui
sont en jeu belle et voici ce sont les
sièges que vous voyez en jaune je vais
afficher la chambre l'a fait le sénat
avant sa dissolution
il faut une majorité de 51 sièges pour
l'emporter pour avoir la majorité
c'est exactement le nombre que
détiennent les républicains actuellement
les démocrates en ont 49
mais regardez le nombre anne-marie de
sièges en bleu pâle et site
ça ce sont les sièges détenus par les
démocrates qui sont ce soir en élections
pour bien se comprendre si les
démocrates espèrent toujours avoir la
chance de remporter le sénat ce soir ça
paraît difficile parce qu'ils doivent
non seulement aller faire des gains ici
mais conserver l'ensemble de ses sièges
en bleu pâle alors il faut s'attendre à
ce que les républicains qui ont une
tâche beaucoup plus facile c'est à dire
garder ce qu'ils ont déjà maintiennent
le contrôle du sénat
voici donc la carte on va revenir sur
certains états au cours de la soirée qui
sont particulièrement à surveiller je
vous parlais de la chambre des
représentants je le disais les 435
sièges sont en élection c'est pas
partout où il ya des courses entendons
nous ont dit que des courses serrées
dans à peu près 70 de ces
circonscriptions la majorité au sénat à
la chambre des représentants ses 218
présentement les républicains ont une
majorité confortable
ça pourrait changer au cours de la
soirée si les démocrates espèrent faire
des gains ce soir c'est ici c'est à la
chambre des représentants elle
s'appelait chiffre magique c'est 23 mai
voir aller jusqu'à une cinquantaine de
sapeurs montferrand s'est ouvert merci
elle aura alors donné un coup d'état et
dont sacrément bon soir devant soir
charles philippe bonjour alors vous
particulièrement caisse quel est l'enjeu
on peut parler de référendum pour
monsieur tron
mais hier il semble dire que c'est une
niche comme s'est pas occupé dès la
course des représentants et c'est
vraiment de la politique il faut le dire
d'une part elle aussi son comportement
évidemment la façon qui le traitaient
les honduriens qui ont mené à la
frontière envoyé l'armée ça demande une
certaine façon qui est un peu anti
américain président américain sont pas
habitués les courses 2 qui ont déjà été
ce côté des démocrates à 1 au kentucky
et puis celui du dixième district au
budget ni fair italie ses côtés du
démocrate donc ça donne l'espoir pour
les démocrates y en ad'autres tennessee
y en a d'autres où mes doigts sont rayo
et secteur a donc se voir fixer massada
1 et là quand même
l'autre aspect qui est important pour la
chambre des représentants ainsi que s'il
ya plus de monde qui votent puis à date
on semble à leur âge 81 millions
peut-être un peu plus ça faisait ça
donne tout cela en temps vous ne
manquerez plus les gens voient des
changes d'une aura non moins été le cas
dans le vote par anticipation en quoi as
tu t'en vas
ouais et pour vous car elle présente les
enjeux on a vu des images un des grands
évènements je n'étais juste derrière
semaine on peut pour même ce référendum
sur kraft depuis deux ans je pense qu'on
aurait pour des heures à montrer puisque
s'est passé mais je ces dernières
semaines de cavale en à la tuerie osant
à au colis piégé
à la frontière et cetera est-ce que
c'est là dessus que porte cette
élection-là cette question d'identité
sont importantes le frob qui veut
défendre la majorité blanche devant
l'invasion c'est quoi pour petit
discours que tu chantes pas tenus en
tout cas on en a parlé justement cette
question des migrations le lien entre
immigration et sécurité et identité
américaine
mais quand on regarde les courses par
exemple pour les postes de gouverneurs
les questions sont un peu plus locales
que sont de parler beaucoup de santé à
l'intérieur de chacun des états la
question des conditions préexistantes
pour l'assurance santé par exemple la
question du prix des du prix des
médicaments
la question de l'accès à l'avortement
aussi pour les femmes dans tout ça a été
sur la table on en a plus entendu parler
jusqu'ici on en entend peu parler sur la
scène nationale b c'est c'est là dessus
que les gens vont voter essentiellement
à tout le moins pour les postes de
gouverneurs et pour certaines courses à
la chambre des garçons on n'en parle pas
beaucoup des gouverneurs mais en a 36 en
élection sur les cinquante années 14 le
stade ou de système ou six ans et des
élections justes quelques élections à la
fois ils sont nés sont élus pour six ans
pour 4 en général et les agressions il
ya des tabous dans une coupe deux cycles
de deux ans alors pourquoi c'est
important les bornes argent c'est parce
que vous savez aux etats unis
qu'est-ce que il la carte électorale à
tous les dix ans donc dû me lever savons
maintenant ils vont refaire davantage
les capteurs l'état et dans un certain
état et y ont déjà des commandes des
commissions indépendantes la pensée
libérale puis avec la cie ont une
majorité d'un chambre ils peuvent
largement concurrentiel
l'a4 la nouvelle carte des scènes il a
essentiellement pour résumer c'est
s'aider des comptes et qui n'ont pas
toujours une cohérence au niveau
géographique - une cohérence au niveau
partisan donc les démocrates sont pas
tellement différents des républicains
les lieux où l'autre qui top de pouvoir
jouer dans ces comptes et l'a donc dans
certains comtés comme exemple vous allez
quitter contrit baromètre un conte est
un swing states qu'on appelle et les
claques et ils disent beaucoup d'avoir
cet état là parce que en 2020 soit sur
les chances de le décider
essentiellement c'est et à leur puits
salé l'impact il eut à la chambre des
représentants ils ont pour pour les
prochains congrès puis comme saviez des
élections tous les deux on imagine passé
ici lequel le parti au pouvoir puis se
redessiner la carte électorale
ici au canada c'est le fédéral qui quand
même qu'ils aient département
redessinent la carte mais aux états unis
c'est les étoiles dans une élection
fédérale qui détermine et même au niveau
des règles du jeu aujourd'hui on est là
qu est la question en géorgie où ils ont
libre démocrates espèrent que c'était si
rome devienne un gouverneur de l'état
pourquoi parce que elle elle se bat
aussi contre la suppression des votes
c'est un enjeu dans cet état leur
démocratie mise à l'épreuve et ça c'est
la première noire à fabien la musique
est comme ça je pense que laissait
vraiment à l'étroit lutte que les gens
regardent des moquettes rotax réclamé
brink's en géorgie et monsieur guerlain
of le livre est pour vous charles du
sénat on aime chez lui la participation
d'une présidentielle de mi-mandat
tellement c'est pourquoi autant
d'excitation cette course parce que le
nombre il ya beaucoup tu fais annoncé et
il pourrait y avoir peut-être quand même
un nombre d'électeurs et d'électrices
lors de ces élections de mi-mandat qui
surpasse ou surclasse un bon nombre
d'élections précédantes de mi-mandat
savez les élections de mi mandat sont
généralement très peu suivi comment sont
même par ici à montréal ou au québec on
suit très peu ces élections de mi-mandat
le fait qu'on a un plateau comment c'est
en soi une révélation de l'intérêt de la
passion pour la politique américaine et
oui c'est historique parce que au fond
ce qu'on veut savoir c'est ce que 2016
confirme une tendance celle de la
présidence de 30 pour longtemps où était
ce un fait exceptionnel
il ya deux ans que 30 soit élu est-ce
qu'on revient à quelques données
fondamentales de l'humeur électorales
auxquelles on avait été habituée vous
savez juste une chose intéressante le
nombre de personnes qui ont voté pour
obama en 2012 et qui ont voté pour 30 en
2016 alors la question ce soir est de
savoir surtout dans les banlieues des
grandes villes
est ce que ces gens là vont revenir au
parti démocrate tous ces gens là vont
continuer d'appuyer leurs gouverneurs
leurs sénateurs ou leurs représentants
de district républicain plusieurs des
courses de au sénat que je surveille ce
soir sont en terre républicaine
maintenant alors ces sénateurs et
sénatrices avait été élu avant que dans
notre propre n'arrive au pouvoir alors à
titre d'exemple de voir un jo dans le
lit en difficulté ça semble être le camp
genevois en indienne
et pas par quelques petits pourcentages
de différence mais pour l'instant une
marge assez importante tend à démontrer
que pour ces sénateurs et sénatrices ce
plan je pense à claire mccaskill au
missouri démocrate ça pourrait être une
soirée difficile vraiment difficile
parce que l'électorat dans leur état est
devenu souvent pas mal républicain et
son salon mais très bientôt et paraît-il
que le taux de satisfaction à l'égard du
président de chambre est le plus bas
depuis plusieurs présidences autour de
41 pour cent à l'heure des élections de
mi mandat il a fait beaucoup campagne au
niveau sénatoriale à toi public en
gâtine en négligeant la chambre des
représentants comme si ça ne dérange pas
de perdre la chambre des représentants
peut-être quoi de se trouver un ennemi a
donné un nouvel ennemi je pense que
c'est qu'un que c'est une mauvaise
stratégie politique c'est évident il ya
le dieu regardez où si la chambre des
représentants que jamais oublier que la
première tare de chambre des
représentants 6e surveiller le budget
des états unis d'amérique sans budget
toute sa politique même étrangères vont
être mis en doute même sa politique a
été admis en d'autres langues c'est
important la chance de percer des puits
avait déjà la majorité au sénat
varane mais ils l'avaient parce que
c'est louche on voyait la vague bleue
celui but de la chambre des
représentants
donc pourquoi qui s'est pas dirigé la
personne m'avait skype il ya beaucoup de
choses qu'on ne sait pas parler
d'économie aussi je pense que tout
avantage quand même à garder le sénat
était plus facile à gagner puis ils vont
pas avoir gagné son pari d'avoir
certaines ambitions
oui comme ça vous savez que si jamais il
y avait une motion d'une chambre des
représentants démocrates pour link
between ça prend deux sièges sénat puis
suisse protège la bien à plus de sucre
ont continué à nommer des juges
il va continuer à nommer des
ambassadeurs et ses secrétaires de son
cabinet a surtout qui veut se
débarrasser de ses chine ce parce qu'il
soit d'abord quelques unes à lens à la
base de ces chiffres mettent le paquet
regina qui pourrait peut-être un jour
quand je dis monsieur monsieur
dans sa stratégie
je pense que c'était mieux de s'assurer
qu'ils grand angle le ceiops la chambre
des représentants s'est toujours plu
surtout quand un taux de satisfaction
dans vos 50 % c'est ce que tous les
présidents pouvoir perdre des siens une
soixantaine il faut pas l'oublier est
toxique pour plusieurs républicains
aussi et quand il a parlé de s'attaquer
au droit du sol notamment même si le
fait de façon plus réaliste l'enfant que
les migrants illégaux il voulait mettre
fin à ça pour plusieurs républicains et
ça a été un petit
il ya eu un petit goût de revenez-y en
dix ans mais nous on ne peut pas
vraiment appuyer ce genre de démarche
il est toxique ou six pour les
républicains alors tellement de choses à
se dire on est ensemble quelques heures
alors regardez toutes vos bonnes
expertise des analyses pour les
prochains résultats et qui vont venir va
poursuivre la mission
après cette brève pause avec nos invités
et leur attitude si nous gagnons ce soir
ça va envoyer un message à monsieur
chanter monsieur descente est également
à savoir que la politique de la haine de
la dissension de séparation et bien que
ces politiques auront fait leur temps au
moins dans ces élections ci que les gens
sortent et votre peau
[Musique]
et moi je veux être là gouverneur qui va
s'assurer qu'on voit pas uniquement
atlanta les autres villes plus vous se
développer mais jusqu'au sud que cette
ville sous et puisse réussir son
potentiel
cerrone qui pourrait faire l'histoire
aujourd'hui celle été élu parce qu'elle
convoite le poste de gouverneur de la
georgie un état du sud est des états
unis
tout près de la floride j'en parle avec
elisabeth vallet qui participe à un
événement tout à fait spécial ce soit en
compagnie d'experts et d'analystes cette
élection bonsoir elizabeth
bonsoir et merci d'être avec nous à
distance on vous aurait aimé sur le
plateau mais vous êtes la bonne vous
vivez pleinement votre passion je pense
comme c'est une présidentielle
ce soir en ce jour je lui demandai à nos
invités ce soir ce qu'elle représentait
cette élection avec quelques résultats
qui sont disponibles maintenant avec
convient d'entendre madame stacy brown
dont on sait qu'il ya de plus un nombre
record de femmes qui se pressent qu'il
est pour vous l'élément clé de cette
élection sont à son caractère historique
qu'est ce que vous surveillez aussi
voilà trois questions en rafale
son caractère historique tient vraiment
à la place que les gouverneurs vont
jouer pour 2020 on sait pas s'il en
toute probabilité le sénat devrait être
gagnée par les républicains et la
définition des cartes électorales
l'impact que tout ces élections va avoir
maintenant c'est l'horizon de dans deux
ans de l'élection présidentielle donc
effectivement vous parliez de ses six
abrams est quelque chose de déterminant
pour que justement les gouverneurs qui
participe beaucoup à la définition des
circonscriptions qui joue un rôle clé
dans l'organisation du vote
et bien que ces gens-là participe en
courage la votation des minorités pour
2020 et assure une représentation pleine
et entière en fait de l'intégralité de
la population américaine époque ce qu'on
a vu là c'est à dire des des élections
qui vont laisser quelle que soit l'issue
d'ailleurs un goût doux amer en raison
de cette pratique et pendant que je vous
parle en main le résultat concernant
thomas stacy brown
une came avec seulement 7% des suffrages
dépouillés s'est pas beaucoup vous allez
me dire mais qu'elle devance avec 63%
des voix
kemp qui comme secrétaire d'état de la
georgie contrôler ou si la machine
électorale il ya déjà écouté on se pose
beaucoup de questions sur le caractère
démocratique la suppression des voix
vous qui le connaissez très bien ce
système là oui qu'est ce que ça implique
ce que c'est que cette façon de faire
pour l'exercice du droit de vote c'est
un problème de légitimité lorsque les le
vote populaire lorsque les gens
l'impression que lorsqu'ils se rendent
au bureau de vote ça ne compte pas ou
qui l'ont qu'ils courent des risques
même à se rendre aux bureaux de vote où
qu ils seront renvoyés à la maison
la légitimité des élus est en cause et
je pense que c'est un élément important
tout ce dont on parle depuis deux ans
c'est cette question de légitimité la
légitimité du congrès qui a le taux
d'approbation le plus bas depuis
longtemps la légitimité d'un président
qui a été élu avec une minorité de
suffrages populaires
donc j'ai le sentiment que c'est vous
savez on a déployé sur le terrain des
observateurs de l'osce et est donc
d'aider le sénégal et des observateurs
qui vont regarder observer les
mécaniques électorale justement parce
que il y a des doutes sur à dans un
certain nombre d'états sur les pratiques
qui sont mises en place et je pense que
le socle de la démocratie c'est sa
légitimité est toujours sur le système
électoral ya monsieur club anticipait
déjà des fraudes électorales sans aucune
preuve ce qu'il avait allégué en 2016
déjà toujours sans aucune preuve donc et
donc que cette poursuite qui serait déjà
intenté parce que sept buts ça va vite
le dépôt de poursuites pour empêcher
quand même tenue même de faire le
dépouillement de faire le compte des
voix
absolument et c'est ça le savez le fait
qu'il soit juge et partie et est
vraiment un des problèmes les plus
centraux de cette élection et vous savez
des primes des gens qui ne peuvent pas
accéder aux urnes
il y en a dans tous les états on l'a vu
au dakota du nord avec les les tribus
autochtones
on le voit aussi on est obligé
d'encadrer le processus de vote par
exemple en arizona
les groupes comme l'aclu jouent un rôle
déterminant pour essayer de justement
éventuellement de poursuivre ce que vous
disiez les pratiques les gouvernements
qui auraient des pratiques inadéquates
on est on a une démocratie à l'échelle
d'un continent qui a beaucoup de
dysfonctionnements qui fonctionne bien
par ailleurs il ya beau aussi beaucoup
de questions référendaires sur le
bulletin de vote
donc il ya cette espèce de paradoxes que
sont les états unis entre une démocratie
à certains égards très abouti à certains
égards une démocratie directe et d'autre
part des dysfonctionnements très
important au niveau de la représentation
et de l'expression du vote
en même temps ce qui peut être
intéressant pour la suite parce qu'on
s'attend une vague bleue est ce que est
ce que vous y croyez vous à ce moment ci
l'onho de la chambre des représentants
compte tenu de la petite taille leur le
fameux gerrymandering le découpage le
contrôle politique si on veut des
districts et des messages les modèles
pour l'instant prédisent effectivement
une vague lieu à la chambre des
représentants c'est un élément important
la chambre des représentants a des
pouvoirs dans kent on va avoir la
possibilité de d'enquêté plus avant sur
les pratiques de l'administration shop
elle va aussi avoir la possibilité
d'organiser d'autres une protection plus
importantes du procureur spécial donc
aller les pauvres de sept chambres sont
importants
ça avoir un impact mais bien évidemment
d'un à pâques limité parce que le sénat
la chambre haute
de toute évidence et là encore on parle
de modélisation mais les modèles
semblent dire que le sénat devrait
rester républicain une dernière question
toujours sur le système électoral côté
les abeilles quand on voit les files
d'attentes on est en démocratie
impressionnant on est en 2018 ont des
heures d'attentes
toutes ces élections sur un bulletin de
voix c est quoi yann des bulletins qui
ont six cépages puis n'est pas facile
d'exercer son droit de vote qui est pas
que les taux de participation
généralement lors de ces élections saad
se tourne au cours de 36 40 % maximum
c'est important de souligner ça aussi
non oui et et si les gens vont voter en
nombre beaucoup plus important notamment
les jeunes ça va être une très belle
victoire de la démocratie parce que vous
avez raison les bulletins de vote sans
l'ont ils sont complexes certains
bulletins de vote
le demande requiert de la part de
l'électeur 45 minutes d'attention pleine
et entière pour arriver à le lire du
début jusqu'à la fin
donc ça fait partie des contraintes qui
sont imposés en quelque sorte au vote et
vous avez raison les files d'attentes
sont très longues c'est pour ça que les
gens votent beaucoup par anticipation
ils ne sont pas dégagées de leur travail
pour aller voter
il y a beaucoup de contraintes qui sont
mises et quelque part et il y a il faut
vraiment vouloir voter pour le faire aux
états unis donc il faut aussi
reconnaître cet élément là si le taux de
participation augmentée c'est qu'enfin
les américains ont réalisé que le leur
vote à ces élections de mi-mandat
compter et contiennent manière
importante les appels au vote ont été
entendus par plusieurs millions de
personnes on verra le résultat au cours
de cette soirée merci les à béton
absolue nous laisse retrouver vos
invités qu'ils allaient vivre une soirée
électorale tout en suspense et je pense
avant tout en nuances
on se reparle au cours des prochaines
heures merci les bêtes je vous en prie
merci à tout à l'heure et laurent
terrière des résultats quelques-uns des
résultats justement d'élite conserver on
savait que la lutte au texas avait la
possibilité d'être serré ce soir on en a
la preuve en ce début de soirée faut
dire qu'il ya un très faible pourcentage
des voix dépouillées seulement 2% des
bulletins de vote dépouillés mais bateau
hors que le candidat démocrate ce
nouveau candidat qui est vu comme une
vedette montante du parti démocrate est
en avance mince avance disons le 51% sur
têt clou ce qui est quand même l'un des
piliers du parti républicain alors ce
sera une lutte assurément à surveiller
au cours des prochaines minutes
passons maintenant à la floride ça aussi
c'est une lutte très serrée où rick
scott l'actuel gouverneur de la floride
est en avance là aussi faiblement 50,1 %
des voix ce en avance donc sur bill
nelson qui lui en a 49 % péninsule qui
est sénateur de la floride depuis 2000
donc depuis 18 ans et terminons
maintenant avec l'indy
là aussi voilà les résultats sont un peu
moins serré joe d'anomie le démocrate
est en train de perdre son siège contre
mike brown qui obtient 56% des voix
jordan riz en a 39 et ya à peu près 40%
des bulletins de vote dépouillés je vous
parle aussi d'une autre lutte celle du
gouverneur de floride
hendrik gollum et surveiller pourrait
être le premier gouverneur noir des
etats unis
mais ça ne va pas très bien pour lui je
regardais les premiers résultats c'est
très très serré et c'est son adversaire
210 qui semble en avance jusqu'à preuve
du contraire de santis qui est très pro
très impliqué mener des campagnes
publicitaires assez assez sale ou dur
enfin j'adore haineuse à son endroit de
gala de gala mange une image non parce
qu'il fait partie est l'homme de cette
de cette catégorie de républicains pour
qui l'identité blanche
la perte des hommes de cerbère par les
femmes des blancs de se faire envahir
par les noirs et les chrétiens par
d'autres est ce que ton parti un peu de
ce portrait de santis oui de santé c est
dans cette lignée là tout à fait
4' alimente aussi depuis un certain
temps alors j'ai rejoint que fait avec
nous acceptable même s'il est à
washington christine d'autres pas loin
la maison blanche j'écoutais on vient
d'en remettre des communiqués de sa race
en deux
qui dit que le président regarde les
résultats bien tranquillement avec sa
famille mais qu'il veut poursuivre le
chemin vers la prospérité et la sécurité
on peut pas retourner en arrière on
entendu beaucoup dire ça et se moquer
beaucoup de le bilan d'obama
il commence déjà à blanc mais paul ryan
ne peut-être d'une défaite de la chambre
des représentants
oui bon ça on s'en doutait un peu que
monsieur de chambre
même s'il perd la chambre ce soir il va
tenter de transformer cette défaite en
victoire
c'est une c'est la façon qu'il opère
c'est comme ça qu'on le connaît
j'aimerais quand même qu'on parle de
l'effet kavanagh si vous permettez
anne-marie on a senti ici il ya
peut-être je vous dirais avant qu'il ya
les audiences au sénat sur la nomination
du juge de la cour suprême
on a senti ici qui commençait à y avoir
une vague bleue et lorsque c'est arrivé
la sphère cavanna on a senti que ça a
redonné du souffle aux républicains et
ce soir il ya une lutte qui incarne très
très bien ça les deux joues comme on les
appelle ici à washington joe donnelly en
inde y en a qui est en train de perdre
son siège qui a voté contre le juge
kavanagh et joe mansion lui qui est en
train de gagner son siège ou de
maintenir son siège en virginie
occidentale qui a voté contre le jeu
pour le juge kavanagh alors avancé ce
qu'on disait il ya les votre peau pour
s'en est tenu à son vote anti kavanagh
et madame mais casqués mekas yellow sea
au missouri où c'est très très très
serré alors c'était fait kavanagh se
fait sentir là jusqu'au fin fond des
états unis dans plusieurs courses
sénatoriales très important pour les
démocrates et aussi pour les république
d'alors prenons les faits kavanagh de
front parce que c'est cette vise 40
remond les hommes et les femmes d'après
vous cette divise les hommes et les
femmes ça divise les républicains et les
démocrates et je pense que les gens que
ce soit les républicains et démocrates
en fait se sont servis de ça pour
illustrer ce ce clash des valeurs qu'on
est en train de voir aux états unis et
pour les républicains évidemment ça fait
partie de cette rhétorique que tant
qu'il ya pas de preuve qu'il ait pas de
procès on ne peut pas accuser quelqu'un
de présomption d'innocence campagne de
salissage victimisation aussi de
kavanagh je pense que c'est ce qui a
marqué la donne aussi et pour les
démocrates mais c'est les femmes
essentiellement qui ont alimenté ce
mouvement là pour dire ben il y avait
suffisamment d'éléments pour à tout le
moins exercé un droit de réserve et
remplacé kavanagh par quelqu'un d'autre
et ça beaucoup pas la risée les gens
m'aimaient monsieur latreille a tout à
fait raison on a vu les sondages
remontée pour les républicains pour 3par
particuliers à partir du moment où
kavanagh a été a été confirmée mais
parce que plusieurs qui estime
jean-philippe au fond on n'aime pas de
from may chez les républicains
mon ami politique et son juge
c'est au centre de sa campagne
électorale s'ils ont des chances de voir
nos politiques être mise en application
mise de l'avant
on se fout un peu de savoir quel
caractère ou quel ton auquel vulgarité
recours le président vous avez raison
parce que dans certains focus groupes
qui ont été filmée récemment où on
demandait des électeurs et des
électrices pro 30 des électeurs et des
électrices pro démocratique anti trempe
de se prononcer vous voyez que souvent
ce qui revenait de l'avant avec 30 c il
parle mal
il est poli son hit traitement les
femmes on est d'accord qu on lui
retirerait son twitter mais ils livrent
la marchandise
il fait ce qu'il dit il dit ce qu'il
fait c'est pour ça qu'on l'aï lu et ce
message là et visiblement écouté par
beaucoup de gens et je rebondis encore
un peu sur la sphère kavner karen
absolument raison le fossé est très
évident par exemple dans une course
sénatoriale que j'ai suivi avec
attention comme tout le monde je pense
l'américain pointe au dakota du nord
volant de sénatrice qui s'est prononcé
vous l'avez déjà entendu je pense qu'il
ya un mot le dire elle se regarde dans
le miroir et le dis en toute conscience
je ne peux pas voter pour la nomination
du juge kavanagh et du même coup elle
avait dit j'ai probablement perdu mes
élections parce qu au dakota du nord on
est en terre républicaine là aussi un
état que dans l'autre à part emporté
remporter il y a deux ans madame
cinquième face à son adversaire avait
peu de chances d europe peu de chance
probablement pour l'emporter pourquoi
c'est important de s'attarder deux
secondes au dakota du nord parce qu'il
n'y a aucune chance mon humble avis on
verra ce que les autres disent ce soir
que les démocrates puissent remporter le
sénat s'ils ne sont pas capables de
préserver au moins ce siège de dakota ce
que cet argent au fond on a besoin de
faire des gains à la chambre des
représentants sont une chose mais les
républicains ont besoin de faire des
gains au sénat pour être dans une marge
de sécurité au sénat parce que les votes
du sénat sont pas beaucoup et parce que
après chaque vote comme on l'a vu avec
le sénateur mais kane
et c'est ce qu'ils vont ils vont faire
un gain au moins deux toits que de 2
août et certains contenus comme vous
savez on ne laisser tomber la règle du
60 votre pour eux juge de la cour
suprême donc si vu qu'il est juste ou
mais en réalité c'est un stade et boch
les démocrates l'ont enlevé sur
certaines nominations et public et l'ont
étendue sur d'autres donc
fondamentalement s'il te plaît le
populaire mais bon enfant de maternelle
sont à blâmer et avec 6 5 ans les 51 49
6 à 53 54
il ya aucun doute qu'ils étaient dans
une situation assez confortable mais
pour revenir à 4-4 n'incarne a
définitivement mobiliser la base est ce
ces questions là je sens si c'est plus
que le parti de tron j'ai eu beaucoup
sur la carte culturelle identitaire
l'immigrant meslier des républicains
quand même qu'ils sont fondamentalement
les conservateurs et pour eux
à voir le juge au pouce crème qui
conservateurs s'étaient pas très très
important et olive lama choisi le
dernier point que je ferai c'est un
point que les formations post cup
d'année c'est une des premiers me et
mi-terme depuis plusieurs années qu'il
ya pas un économique et en quittant à
lens
y'a pas une guerre impopulaire vite où
on n'entend quasiment pas parlé de
qu'est ce qui se passe en irak en
afghanistan et au yémen des américains
sont pas sur le sol
y a personne qui perd ses tests étaient
effectivement résidents en fait c'est
comme s'il y avait deux campagnes
la campagne menée par les démocrates
gardent on le voit dans des rallyes dans
des grands mouvements il ya un mouvement
de fond
fufu successeur ali les enfants pendant
qu'ils ont une rhétorique aussi l'
extraordinaire quand on écoute rempli
une vague bleu à l'âme
la chambre des représentants si à cause
du bris de covenants
parce que les femmes bombarder
massivement au niveau de la chambre de
la place en scène est d'ailleurs pour la
première fois de l'histoire la majorité
des candidats sont des candidates
la parti démocrate finalement les femmes
sont en train de se mobiliser contre la
nomination de karine a et les résultats
vont se voir si jamais une vague bleue
qui promet 100 200 donc c'est ça la
chambre des représentants c'est
exactement là qu'on voit la
fonctionnement
les gens qui disent non à brens de canon
mais qu'est ce qu'elle a ma carte
donnant quatre suspects tous les jours
je suis d'accord avec toi mais autant
que ça mobilise d'aider mon cas ça
mobilise aussi délimiter avec beijing et
hong sac quand quatre hommes est sûre ce
en seulement six buts et les deux
parties déjà qu'ils aiment trop mme
sabah sont mobilisés puis voilà les
casemates trois cas personnel et les
démocrates aux autres c'est à cause de
la vague ou du modèle le sentiment a dit
donc c'est que les deux bras les
démarches et démocrates on voit que
c'est les démocrates qu'on a mais le
financement des corbeilles alors
quelqu'un s'est jamais vu en moyenne
oui mais les femmes les femmes
contribuent davantage aux candidatures
féminines aux candidatures démocrates en
général et ce sont les candidats hommes
républicains qui voient alors leurs
finances mal s'effondrer dans
différentes régions
mais les gens qui votent condom 30
depuis le début sont les femmes il les
gens qui ont commencé à voter comme dans
l'autre on par rapport au brut car
maintenant c'est les femmes et c'est un
phénomène tout à fait nouveau pour le
parti démocrate
oui donc les femmes prennent la main
qu'ils habitent
et là c'est la question de la chance de
passer car si 50 des femmes blanches ont
voté aux attentes rappelons les choses
comme elles sont ouais je suis d'accord
cependant avec trois couples à la clis
normalement le vote démocrat féminin
votre féminin devrait surtout dans les
banlieues chez les gens scolarisés c'est
que les derniers sondages semblent
démontrer que les femmes scolarisés vont
maintenant voter de l'ordre de 60% en
faveur de candidature démocrate
mais attention on revient quand même
d'une période de deux ans où ce score là
était beaucoup moins élevé donc oui
c'est vrai que le vote comme body karine
le vote féminin est très mobilisé c'est
vrai aussi que le parti démocrate
récolte un financement bien supérieur à
celui auquel il était habitué surtout je
le rappelle pour des élections de
mi-mandat qui normalement font dormir
tout le monde on est dans une campagne
de 2 800 millions de dollars au moins
qu'ils auraient été récoltés par le
parti démocrate pour soutenir les
candidatures démocrate dans les
différents comtés et au sénat alors
c'est pas rien que cette mobilisation
christian là-dessus mais je pense que
c'est une petite révolution charles a
tout à fait raison de le mentionner il
ya une majorité de femmes blanches
malgré toutes les accusations
d'inconduite sexuelle qui ont pesé sur
le dow jones en 2016 et ont appuyé
monsieur de chambre mais nous ce qu'on a
vu sur le terrain c'est vraiment oui les
électrices qui votent en ce moment en
masse mais il ya une implication ça
sonnait le réveil des femmes en
politique aux etats unis
le phénomène dans leur chambre alors je
me suis rendu au minnesota l'année
dernière pas tellement longtemps
il ya deux ans pas tellement longtemps
prédation l'investiture il y avait des
femmes qui se présentait la kiné qui ne
connaissait pas du tout la politique qui
n'avait jamais même parler en public
et là il fallait des camps
d'entraînement ce qu'on peut utiliser
une une analogie sportive simplement
pour apprendre à se présenter
raconter leur histoire être pertinente
lever des fonds on leur apprenait
comment faire de la politique est là ce
que l'on voit en ce moment ce nombre
record de femmes qui se présente à ces
élections de mi mandat
c'est le résultat de l'élection de
dongchang et tout ce qui s'en est suivi
a bien merci christian mais on poursuit
après la pause avec d'autres résultats
et d'autres analyses ans avant la pause
en vous disant que la démocrate
christine ahlquist ans de devenir là
mr gouverneur ouvertement un transgenre
elle est présentement en retard sur les
républicains et toujours au vermont pour
les 102 on le disait en début d'émission
a facilement été really a tout de suite
avec d'autres résultats
[Musique]
alors on voit ici justement ces
messieurs descente et ce en floride qui
veut devenir gouverneur il se pose à
monsieur guillaume qui aurait été le
premier gouverneur noir le maire de
tallahassee de quelques résultats avec
ceux ci étaient au moment d'aller voter
ce matin
présentement mince avance mais avance
quand même su alors que quelques
résultats qui éclot cible des luttes
sénatoriales maintenant on va se
transporter du côté du sénat est bien
d'abord parlons de ryder cup au dakota
du nord on le disait tout à l'heure en
si les démocrates avaient à perdre un
siège ce soir c'était probablement celui
là et bien c'est un plus qui est en
train de se produire je vous dirais
parce que selon les derniers résultats
madame ricains pas 33% des voix son
adversaire kevin creamer en a 66 % il ya
à peu près 5% des bulletins de vote qui
ont été dépouillés jusqu'à maintenant
mais déjà ça donne une idée de la
tendance
même s'il faut toujours rester prudent
lorsqu'il ya un pourcentage faible des
voix qui ont été dépouillés or passer
maintenant à l'indiana là aussi les
démocrates sont en difficulté jo
d'annecy qui était là depuis 2012 avait
remporté l'élection de justesse je vous
le rappelle avec seulement 50% des voix
et bien maintenant il traîne derrière
avec 41% des voix et mike brown son
adversaire du côté républicain en à 54,5
je termine avec le texas on va avoir les
yeux rivés au cours de la soirée sur le
texas
on savait que ce serait serré mais
peut-être pas tant que ça là monsieur
cruz vient de reprendre l'avancé avec
52% des voix
monsieur au work en a 48 alors on va
suivre cette lutte parce que ça
s'annonce assez sérieux
oui merci beaucoup à laurent je jouais
maintenant à new york avec sens du style
et professeur de journalisme
international à l'université colombia
bonsoir monsieur style et un bon soir
alors vos impressions jusqu'à maintenant
avec ces premiers résultats est ce que
vous voyez ou non une
vague bleue ou pas les premiers et les
premières luttes au sénat également
raison pour faire des pressions choix on
ne voit pas en grande vague bleue tout
le moment je dirais que si j'étais au
public n je serais assez content c'est
plutôt clair que je peux beaucoup en
matière de contrôle du sénat et dans la
chambre des députés c'est sarah au long
de la soirée
mais certaines certaine élection qui les
sondages donnait comme très très proches
comme l'élection george à pour le
gouverneur était directement pour les
démocrates
c'était maintenant traité c'est dans
beaucoup des sondages donnait comme
vainqueur en floride soit le candidat
pour le governator algues l'homme et
aussi pour le candidat au sénat
démocrate en floride et floride c'est
toujours un état très grave et je pense
que ces premiers résultats sont un peu
un plutôt décevant c'est difficile il y
avait quelques moments de l'exubérance
en texas au bateau alors que sont à
gagner sur tech use mais avec le progrès
du scrutin ça devient plus difficile
ça veut dire que je pense que le
résultat final surtout sur la chambre
des députés
on ne saura plus tard quand on a les
résultats de californie d ostende état
de l'ouest des états unis
mais je ne vois pas le grande vague
bleue est certainement le président
trump peut être plutôt satisfait du fait
qu il a changé le paysage politique
surtout dans l'action du sénat ouais je
m'adresse à vous monsieur
mais ce style et je vous interromps je
m'adresse à vous comme professeur de
journalisme dans parmi tous les enjeux
qu'on a pu identifier la question de
l'immigration
la question de l'identité la question
notamment de l'effet kavanagh il reste
qu'il ya aussi ce clivage entre la
presse traditionnelle et le fox news et
là tu le style de campagne comme menez
monsieur trompe avec un ton assez
hargneux avec ma foi souvent même des
mensonges mais c'est comme ça dans la
population ça ça n'avait pas d'effet ce
que cette image entre la presse
traditionnelle et par les fameuses fait
que nous les fait le terreau natif la
vérité le monde sourit oui en chose
qu'on regarde avec beaucoup d'intérêt et
aussi de préoccupation c'est pas exemple
comme vous savez être pas fait campagne
électorale très très énergiquement dons
pendant les dernières semaines comme
s'il était le candidat pour la
présidence des états unis et a par
exemple le washington post qui tient
compte des mensonges des trains pendant
sa présidence il a il à raconter quelque
chose comme 5 mensonge pour pendant ces
dernières semaines il a raconté quelque
chose comme 30 mensonge prochains jours
il a il adaptera en situation de péril
et de dangers pour le pour le pôle et
pays avec ce cas rival de personnes qui
viennent de rôle de ross et il a changé
un peu certainement la situation au
sénat ça sera très intéressant voir
l'effet de la campagne qu'il a fait
pendant ces dernières se mêlent pas
parce que beaucoup des candidats
républicaine veut comprendre ces 30 et
pour avantage ou un désavantage c'est ça
monsieur ne chante pas disait en
présentant certains ses 15 ans un vote
pour mettre bas
si vous votez bourba vous voter pour moi
c'est voter pour un doux voté pour moi
oui il l'a fait il a fait de cette
élection a sa propre élection et c'est
très intéressant de voir si ça va ou
succès au par une répétition pour 2020
en terminant monsieur stylet vous avez
une candidate dans l'état de new york
qui peut être très intéressante à suivre
très identifiée à la gauche c'est le
répétait la plus jeune élue et alexandra
occasion corp est ce qu'en dit il de sa
course elle
oui ça serait intéressant il ya aussi d
autres d autres candidats intéressants à
voir pendant la soirée après à 9 heures
ou les jours ici à new york
je ferme il y a dans le 19ème siècle de
serait un candidat démocrate qui ce
qu'ils appellent delgado qui a qui a
défilé contre le candidat républicaine
qui était déjà qu'ils se calment fathom
et les deux derniers sondages étaient
avec le démocrate légèrement en vente
âge mais il faut voir twitter le
sculpteur à bayal alors la team six
styles et merci beaucoup depuis new york
ce soir le professionnalisme et le
journalisme dans cette carte a été très
important n'est ce pas la façon dont on
couvre ou pas les enjeux alors je jouais
maintenant en fleuret de le politologue
daniel marié vous êtes professeur de
politique américain l'université
centrale d'irlande où l'on semble se
marier alors l'affairé d'assez il ya des
courses là que l'on surveille
il semble que monsieur c'est très serré
à monsieur des centristes et monsieur
guy l'homme quelle interprétation
comment expliquez-vous les résultats
jusqu'à maintenant
d'abord je voudrais dire que votre
éviter de l'état new york a fait un très
bon tour d'horizon de ce qui se passe on
ne voit pas émerger vraiment de vague
bleue très puissante qui va submerger
les systèmes politiques remarquer qu'il
est encore tôt en ce qui concerne la
floride spécifiquement aux dernières
nouvelles que j'ai eues
de dix minutes les candidats démocrates
professional étaient sur place et par le
candidat républicain pour le sauna de
très peu monsieur scott qui présenteront
le gouverneur républicaine cela
challenge le sénateur démocrate bill
nelson et monsieur scott et day en
avance et parallèlement on voudrait des
queues de rédaction pour le gouverneur
de candidats républicains monsieur de
santis est en avance
google mais ce qui se produit ici c'est
que ces annonces sont très minces et est
ce que je sache aux dernières nouvelles
il ya dix minutes il ya encore beaucoup
de comptes et ont fait de région qui
vote majoritairement démocrates qui ont
pas rapporté de voix donc c'est pas
encore finie peut-être le thème alors
voilà on en est là quelle analyse faites
vous de l'importance d'une victoire ou
d'une défaite par exemple pour les
démocrates à la chambre des
représentants sceller les démocrates
perdent ne gagne pas la majorité à la
chambre des représentants il se
spécialise relevé toi le green est de 28
sièges
sinon pas ça ils savent trop serein que
très tard peut-être même de même aimé
près de metz californie je le vends
auditeurs beaucoup de recompter les voix
un vrai casse - qu'est-ce que ça vous
réserve pour vous faire démocrate est
pas su faire ligré contenu des
différents enjeux
alors je me demande si le démocrate ne
réussissent pas dans les conditions
actuelles à prendre le contrôle de la
chambre des représentants
c'est évident que c'est une validation
du tonnerre pour la politique est-il le
contenu de donateurs ça c'est évident
c'est absolument clé pour et valider ou
invalider pardon le message de notre des
démocrates 22e concours de la majorité
n'a chanté représentants au sénat on
peut leur passer une une perte de
contrôle une paire de confort mais on
peut excuser au sénat une augmentation
des à majorité républicaine parce que la
cartouche n'a favorisé beaucoup les
républicains mais à la chambre des
représentants la carte est différent et
si des démocrates n'est ce pas à prendre
un concours de la chandelle
les représentants alors c'est la gloire
pour donald trump et tout ce qu'il
représente pour vous ce tristement en
quoi la carte des lieux sénatoriales
favoriser les républicains pas écouté
vous savez le sénat est renouvelée au
tiers à chaque 2 1 et les ai beaucoup de
guillemets beaucoup de sièges démocrates
en jeu quand un peu de sièges
républicains alors les démocrates
avaient plus de sièges à défendre et
dans plusieurs états du siège que les
démocrates avaient défendre étaient des
états où on avait voté à majorité
pendant longtemps par 2016 alors dans
ces circonstances de la structure de la
carte favorise des républicains il se
serait pas surprenant et élargissent
leur majorité au sénat deux cas
sénateurs en terminant est ce qu'un
enjeu pour vous qui a été plus
déterminant qu'un hôte si on dit que
c'est un référendum sur crans à b sans
doute l'immigration aux côtés mais ce
titre a pas fait campagne sur
l'immigration pour dénoncer la caravane
la fameuse caravane comme une invasion
de ba a tiré les cheveux sur la tête
parce que c'est rien à voir avec ça mais
c'est un jeu qui peut être si vous les
six martyrs le contrôle des républicains
la charge si ça s'avère que ces mesures
c'est un contrôle tout va très bien
merci beaucoup monsieur n'à rien à
bientôt
on n'a pas pris l'argent c'est pas trop
tôt on n'a pas fini surtout ce soit en
la californie tard dans la nuit dans les
jours qui viennent avec leurs guitares
de votation par la poste
d merci beaucoup et daniel marion
plaisir pour moi est une des luttes
qu'on surveillait en virginie la
démocrate de district numéro 10 ans
virginie jennyfer ou externe à arracher
un siège aux républicains avec 25 mille
voix de majorité on l'écouté
oui cette base nous avons envoyé un
message que nous voulions un meilleur
pays que nous exigeons un meilleur pays
un pays où nous le traitons avec dignité
et respect
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
nous poursuivons à 21h07 cette émission
spéciale sur les élections de mi-mandat
aux etats-unis c'est présentement très
très serré dans la course à la chambre
des représentants soixante cinq
républicains sont élus en avance contre
60 démocrates au sénat 42 sièges sont
présentement acquis aux républicains
comptent 35 e démocrates au québec on
doit y revenir
la mort de bernard landry a provoqué un
concert d'éloges aujourd'hui les
personnalités de tous les horizons
politiques ont salué la mémoire et son
héritage on va prendre le temps
d'honorer cette mémoire de monsieur
andry on écoute quelques réactions et je
souhaite à tous les minutes de la
culture d'avoir un ministre des finances
comme bernard landry qui aimait la
culture et qui était toujours disposé à
faire en sorte que le petit budget d'une
sphère de la culture soient bien
protégés
la persistance dans ses convictions du
réduction totale
j'étais aussi moi je trouvais numéro
mathieu lévesque me suis parisot
monsieur l'embryon grenier ou ont donné
confiance aux québécois ont voulu
envoyer ce message fort d'un
investissement à l'intérieur de la
sphère économique pour justement quand
je le disais tout à l'heure la récupérer
cette liberté conviction confiance et
ténacité combativité
cette personne là était animé d'une
telle confiance dans le peuple québécois
tout un militant un militant qui ne
logent pas qui est toujours de toujours
garder espoir en la capacité du québec
de devenir un pays
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le nom de wikileaks
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
comment
on le sait
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
tous pour dina police secrète cette
campagne électorale assez enlevante pour
certains très dur pour d'autres lui
d'entendre des déclarations de
quelques-unes des personnalités
inconnues sans doute pour nous aussi
mais à surveiller là bas aux etats-unis
puisque elle pourrait marquer l'histoire
politique américaine de laurent vous
avez fait un petit d'échantillonnage
voilà quelques portraits si vous voulez
il y en a pour qui déjà on sent que le
rendez vous avec l'histoire est
peut-être en voie d'être manquer
d'autres pour qui le résultat est encore
à déterminer voici donc une carte avec
ces personnalités
je vous les présente une à une très
rapidement un job je vous en ai déjà
parlé dans les dernières minutes
candidat au poste de gouverneur en
floride il aurait donc été le premier
afro-américain dans ce poste
malheureusement il est à l'arrière ils
tirent de l'arrière contre son
concurrent républicain stacy abraham
aussi on a regardé un extrait tout à
l'heure des le candidate au poste de
gouverneur du côté de la georgie elle
aurait été la première afro-américaine
gouverneur points aux états unis mais
elle aussi tirent de l'arrière au moment
où on se parle
marsha blackburn candidate au poste de
sénatrice au tennessee et bien je peux
déjà vous dire qu'elle a été élue madame
blackburn
elle devient donc la première sénatrice
du tennessee
dans l'histoire il faut quand même le
souligner christina au christ est
candidate au poste de gouverneur du côté
du vermont aux séries qu'elle a trouvé
très peu de chances de l'emporter ce qui
est intéressant c'est que c'est la
première candidate transgenres à vouloir
accéder au poste de gouverneur mais elle
n'y arrivera probablement pas ce soir
deux candidates qui seraient les deux
premières américano musulmane à la
chambre des représentants rachid
athlètes du côté du michigan et ils en
ont marre du côté du minnesota elle est
l'axé drache que vous le dire au poste
de représentant du côté minnesota
puisqu'elle n'avait pas d'opposition
jared polis au poste de gouverneur au
colorado
il est le premier homme ouvertement
homosexuel à être candidat au poste de
gouverneur il est en avance au moment où
on se parle vous en parlait il ya un
instant avec votre invité
l'ex andria occasio cortese 29 ans
serait la plus jeune à la chambre des
représentants à surveiller les résultats
dans l'état de new york
entrée à partir de 21h dont il ya treize
minutes on pourra vous les donnez tout à
l'heure et on suit évidemment les camps
les résultats au texas
d'ailleurs j'ai quelques résultats pour
vous si vous le voulez bien des gens qui
ont été élus au cours des dernières
secondes
commençons d'abord avec mike brown joe
donnelly qui était le sénateur de
l'indiana perd son poste c'est donc une
perte qui rend à peu près les chances
des démocrates d'accéder à une majorité
au sénat
nul mike brown donc sera le nouveau
sénateur de l'indiana
prochain rendez vous maintenant au
tennessee je vous le disais il ya une
seconde marsha blackburn qui est une
conservatrice pur et dur eh bien elle et
elle est élue du côté du tennessee
prochains résultats maintenant on passe
à la virginie occidentale joe mann chine
a été réélu au poste de sénateur du côté
de la virginie occidentale
il est assurément le démocrate le plus
conservateur du sénat et finalement je
pense que c'est le dernier résultat que
nous aurons et c'est le texas je
continue de suivre cette lutte là parce
que les très très serré cinquante quatre
pour cent du vote a été dépouillée
jusqu'à maintenant
écoutez bien ça better work est en
avance avec 49,9 pour cent des voix cruz
est clown tirent de l'arrière 49,4 il le
répète de 54% des voix qui ont été
dépouillés jusqu'à maintenant c'est une
lutte très très serré à surveiller ce
soit alors on va prendre ce cas merci à
laurent à tout à l'heure
on va parler quand même commençant par
le par le texas parce que au groupe ce
n'est pas n'importe quelle personnalité
s'il devait marquer l'histoire les tous
les démocrates ont les yeux tournés vers
lui
jonah hill vous et vous plaît ce
candidat le coup beaucoup parce que
c'est
peut-être moi je les décris un peu comme
une combinaison de robert kennedy et de
barack obama est d'ailleurs le premier
nom du premier nom de la bacardi label
france
parfaitement bilingue de mi quarantaine
et ce soit une bonne soirée parce que je
vous dis honnêtement quand j'ai regardé
toutes les évaluations des différents
sondages je le disais que c'est un
longue charte qui brillait dans la lutte
il peut gagner même s'il perd en
d'autres mots c'est qu'ils vont être une
figure nationale et il va sur la lys la
plupart des gens qui cherchent un vice
pésident en 2020 donc il peut être
intéressant
c'est peut-être encore trop tôt pour
faire des prédictions de gain net pour
les démocrates puisque c'était déjà flex
qui a quitté le sénat n'est pas tant que
ça à dix on officialise on a aussi joué
à l'e2c au texas et du sénat il ya 188
cas les sénateurs qui sait des mocassins
et benson qui était le dernier
donc quand on regarde la situation pour
lui il s'en sort assez bien dans sa
soirée qu est ce qui donne un petit peu
plus désappointant pour les démocrates
qui recherchent à regarder vers l'avenir
s'ils gagnent à mon père si madame et
bruce spence cdc des défaites pour les
personnes qui ont énormément de
potentiel sont assez jeunes pour revenir
et on gage oui mais des gens que les
stars de cheveux sont trentaine gagner
un lot comme on gagne on sera au
minnesota et mitsubishi cosmétiques et
est beaucoup intervenu qui a été reçu
on sait qu'elle a exprimé l'intérêt pour
la présidence dont vous avez trois
personnes qui sont au moins des gens qui
vont tâter le terrain à partir de
janvier 2019 pour savoir s'ils ont des
appuis donc sa matraque ont comme le vo2
à éviter on dit tantôt on n'a pas une
vague bleue dans cette élection le jeu
par la chambre des représentants est
encore gagnable pour lui les démocrates
le cclat caché dans ses filles laissées
nouveau resté lounge où le public est
mais là on va commencer à voir émerger
les futurs jeux vedettes qui vont partir
la spéculation
à partir de janvier publiés qui sur 2012
les élections perpétuelle quête mais en
fait moi ce que je trouve intéressant
c'est justement pour le sud je
m'attendais pas à ce que tant de
changements que ça ok cette vague bleue
nécessairement en mesure où les
démocrates doivent être patient c'est la
démographie qui va finir par l'emporter
dans le sud des états unis
ce qui est intéressant ce qui sera
intéressant à regarder dans les
prochaines minutes dans les prochaines
heures c'est vraiment le midwest parce
que c'est là justement outre on peut
faire des gains alors qu'obama avait
remporté ses étals en 2008 en 2012 et si
jamais les démocrates sont incapables de
reprendre ses sièges là ben justement
pour revenir à ce que jean philippe
détente au ça va être impossible alors
de penser quelque chose n'est qu'une
parenthèse on va être alors dans une
tendance beaucoup plus lourd moi
j'attends de voir davantage de résultats
de loyaux de l'iowa du kansas par
exemple pour voir quelle est la saveur
de cette élection
moi j'ai une question à poser karim qui
puisque vous avez mentionné les deux
espoirs démocrate que ce soit même au
poste de gouverneur qui se dépensent
tellement important que démocrate
madame et brahms et monsieur guerlain
sur deux mois on n'ose pas le dire
ouvertement mais croyez vous qu'il ya
vote
encore un peu anti obama relié à
l'identité blanche dominante qui veut
s'affirmer comme le bain de la misère à
accepter que des noirs
ben après l'assaut de mai mais parce que
surtout ce sont les restrictions on dit
autrement du dur et c'est ça mais il ya
du racisme effectivement mais il ya du
racisme ainsi réalisées d'une certaine
façon avec ces restrictions au droit de
grève
si on regarde juste
gergy et 53 mille inscriptions
électorales sont suspendues par brahim
thiam qui est à la fois candidat et
secrétaires d'état donc de toucher de
gérer les législations de sorts de son
état et 70% de ses suspensions là sur
les listes électorales ce sont les afro
américains
on retrouve la même chose en floride on
retrouve la même chose oui ce concert on
retrouve la même chose au dakota du nord
où ce sont à la fois les autochtones et
à la fois les amis les afro américains
en particulier dans le sud et c'est
clair que ça a un impact c'est clair que
les afro américains ont moins accès au
vote que les blancs en particulier dans
le sud alors élire des noirs dans ces
circonstances là ça devient encore plus
difficile
on sent qu'on a aperçu le racisme
systémique ouest à l'intérieur du
système lui même et est fausse et que
présida qui encouragent et soeurs n'ont
donc aidé à par laquelle son discours
porte et les propos de descente c'était
quasiment ouvertement et un chat c'est
absolument qu'elle a été choisie comme
un pion aux vestiaires l'attrait gratuit
ou oui ben bisous effectivement soirée 6
mais il est encore très présent aux
états unis il est larves et personne
n'ose en parler publiquement et
encourager aussi par le président notre
champ pas l'occasion n'a qu'à penser à
ces remarques
lorsqu'il ya eu ces manifestations
charleville à l'été 2010 est lorsqu'il
dit qu'il y avait des bons des deux
côtés en parlant des mots nazis et des
membres du look ce clan qui
manifestaient alors sa légitime et tout
ça ça fait ressortir ce titre ce vieux
racisme en dormance aux états unis et là
on se dit mais le président parle le
président le dit pourquoi pas nous et
c'est dans cette atmosphère lacombe en
ce moment mais pour revenir sur ce qui
s'est dit sur l'absence d'une vague
bleue ce soir je suis pas tellement
étonné
parce que sur le terrain on sentait nous
la première chose que les gens nous
disaient lorsqu'on tend le micro aux
américains c'est que dans notre chambre
a tenu ses promesses et il s'est
présenté à washington en 2016 en disant
je ne serai pas un politicien comme les
autres je ne serais je ne suis pas
membre de l'establishment jamais cette
politique chez un homme d'affaires mais
je vais tenir mes promesses et il les a
tenus presque unes après les autres
m'ont mise à part son programme
d'infrastructures et le mur qui la
banque qu'il tente de construire les
juges à la cour suprême l'économie qui
va très très bien c'est pas facile pour
les candidats démocrates ce soir de se
battre contre ça un président qui passe
aussi populaire mais qui tient ses
promesses et une économie qui va très
très bien qui carbure au maximum et bien
même temps messieurs 30 nous dit-on amis
côté une publicité qui va hanter son
bilan économique pour cette publicité
vraiment disgracieuses sur sur
l'immigration toujours et parlant à
d'invasion alors christian on va se
parler tout à l'heure je jouais demain
tant jane garbutt professeur et
économiste à l'université du texas
justement là où il ya encore une autre
série bonsoir monsieur galbraith
alors écoutez au moment où je vous parle
de l'été à la dernière seconde
ils sont vraiment au coude à coude de
monsieur cruz et beethoven je pense 49,7
chacun pour 56%
58% des voix exprimées alors d'après
vous qu'est ce qui explique cette fête
cette force du rock parce qu'il est dans
les sondages disaient que monsieur que
vous aller l'emporter par 7 points
d'avance 49.7 49.71 sont au coude à
coude les deux os c'est très intéressant
à ne sait vraiment une mobilisation à de
très importants des jeunes et des
nouveaux votants du voisin inscrits aux
aubettes euro vaut que si ça tient
ça m'étonnerait beaucoup qu'il gagne à
la fin
mais qui là qu'il arrive à avoir
8 47% même 15% de la voûte de la tva au
texas ce serait un événement très
important le plus le compagne et
manquera le plus réussi depuis 20 ans de
l'état et que pensez-vous à l'échelle
nationale de la campagne de monsieur
tremblay pour les pour et les
commentaires disons des personnes
interrogées à droite à gauche qu'ils
baissent on n'aime pas monsieur chrome
on aime ce qu'il a fait l'économie va
bien c'est pas comme à l'époque de
clinton et id economy stupid métier d
hayden qui étaient ces d'identité qui
conte qu'est ce que vous pensez de ce
dilemme là il n'a pas misé tellement sur
son bilan économique pour censurer fine
et leur chance ils ont toujours une
certaine la possibilité de gagner le
contrôle de la chambre des représentants
ils vont perdre 3 4 sièges au sénat a
donc ça en effet ces matches nuls mais
avec une avec une différence important
que si la chambre des représentants
tombe à tous les démocrates
ils ont rendu une position à washington
beaucoup plus important beaucoup plus
gros forcée qui est qu'auparavant mais
quand même ils ont surestimé c'est leur
chance à saint yzan ils ont trop fait
trop confiance aux sondages ils n'ont
pas présenté une programme national ni
sur le pont économique ni sur les
affaires étrangères a tant qu'à à épi
ils n'ont vraiment pas donné une bonne
raison pour sauf 1 souffre la réaction
contre monsieur tron est pour propos
pour l'heure leur équipe dans ces
élections il faut gagner il faut
apprendre certains laissant pour pour la
prochaine fois
mais en fait ils ont quand même bout et
tenter de faire campagne ce quelque
chose qui touche de très près
beaucoup d'américains c'est évidemment
la santé à le fameux obamacare qu'ils
veulent préserver les démocrates et ça
n'aurait pas suffi d'après vous oui mais
c'est une question 13 ans on dit du
parce que le lot l'obamacare c'est qu'il
programme avec un certain attrait mais
aussi beaucoup de problèmes
donc ce n'est pas tout à fait clair que
ce soit une question de la première
importance à pau pour les électeurs pour
vraiment gagner pour vraiment avoir une
vague électorale il faut que les
démocrates représentent une position de
changements beaucoup plus profond que ça
en fait cet aveu je vous entends bien
j'ai l'impression que vous nous entendez
dire que dans le fond les démocrates ont
laissé toute la place à donner aux
chromes sans programme sans les deux
chiffres de ses serments une campagne
qui n'a pas su parler ou convaincre les
américains et que la personnalité de
chomp est passé en 2d au second plan on
aimait mieux ces politiques tels le
président m'ont s'arrange avec ses ça se
gâte pour le meilleur et pour le pire
monsieur le président à ne sont pas
toujours que la meilleure mais quand
même je ne garde que c'était un plaisir
de vous par wifi depuis le texas on
verra bien si quel sera le gagnant de
cette lutte encore une fois très serré
entre betomorrow ce que on l'appelle
beto est telle cause merci beaucoup
monsieur gardel prochains mois merci
alors dans la mission se retrouve un
petit peu plus tard et toujours pas de
résultat pour le chef de la minorité
démocrate des représentants utiliser un
type pelosi a que quand même 60 18 ans
qui est à la fois adulé et critique
contribuer à amasser beaucoup d'argent
pour le démocrate lors de cette campagne
s'est adressé à ses trois pilotes
quelques minutes dans l'écouté michael
sheen à mes amis ce soir une victoire
historique
notre portée on n'a pas voulu au nom
d'un parti mais pour les familles
travaillante de l'amérique est une
victoire pour notre pays à rétablir les
freins le contrepoids dans notre
constitution en or et la vision de nos
fondateurs et sacrifice de vous en mets
femmes en uniforme et les aspirations de
toute notre jeunesse
[Musique]
c'est le démocrate ben et taureaux qui
actuellement est en avance sur telle
course très légèrement on le voit ici
avec sa famille ce matin au moment
d'aller voter je vous rappelle que c'est
une course sénatoriale aux hôtes exa ce
qui très très suivi c'est très très
serré de rangs très serrés d'ailleurs
parlons-en du texas à l'instant on y
revient parce que maintenant 70% des
bulletins qui ont été dépouillés
résultats jusqu'à maintenant le
démocrate ben eto o rourke est en avance
avec 50,7 % des voix et ted cruz tirent
de l'arrière avec 48 7% alors c'est très
très serré ya aucun réseau américain qui
pour l'instant a déclaré qui que ce soit
vainqueur de ce côté là parce que la
lutte est encore bien vienne importante
du côté de la forêt de c'est la même
chose on a eu notre lutte très serrée de
ce côté là c'est rick scott le
gouverneur actuel de l'état qui est en
avance il à 50,3 % des voix et bill
nelson qui est quand même sénateur
depuis 18 ans depuis 2000 tirent de
l'arrière 49,7 %
là-bas 98% des voix ont été dépouillés
jusqu'à maintenant
alors on est sûr que le résultat sera
très très serré de ce côté-là au dakota
du nord
eh bien là c'est moins serré les ideapad
kamla démocrates tirent de l'arrière
sérieusement avec 34,7 % des voix son
adversaire républicain en a 65
je termine en vous parlant de la chambre
des représentants écoutez on ne
s'attendait pas à ce que ce soit si long
avant d'avoir des gains du côté des
démocrates à la chambre des
représentants pour l'instant il ya
soixante quinze démocrates qui ont gagné
leurs sièges 80 du côté des républicains
les démocrates sont en avance dans 31
dans 31 comtés
il en faut 21 pour obtenir la majorité
alors on est on est toujours dans un
territoire pour l'instant où il est
possible d'avoir une majorité démocrate
du côté de la chambre des représentants
alors merci laurent tout à l'heure alors
je jouais meta robert dit on peut
réussir de sciences politiques
maintenant je mange un beau panel je
m'en vais pas tout ce temps
trois choses alors alors et avec
christian latreille aussi quelques
commentaires vous avez vu dans les
résultats parce qu'on va y envoyer la
rafale chaufferie et s'est rapidement
moi je surveillais le sénat je pense que
le sénat et les carottes sont cuites
comme dit l'autre pense que cela serait
très étonnant je vois même pas comment
les démocrates peuvent aller chercher
une majorité ils ont sauvé quelques bons
vieux meubles djoman chine par exemple
depuis longtemps sénateurs démocrates en
virginie occidentale le plus
conservateur comme disait laurent de
démocrates
on dirait presque un public et un faux
démocrates parmi les démocrates l'ont
arrêté pour kavanagh ils ont été vos
caves à nancy vous dire à quel point il
est pro trappe
maintenant ce qui est intéressant de
surveiller ou d'avoir constaté ce soir
c'est la défaite cuisante de john
vernile indiana alors les sondages
prédisaient que ça allait être difficile
il y avait dans les sondages une mince
majorité mais pourtant il est des faits
karine jusqu'à maintenant qu'est-ce que
ça vous dit que c'est pas bien quand
même des luttes d'un de représenter un
important tous les démocrates on
s'attend à ce que les démocrates les
trottoirs à la soirée pour dire que
c'est pas que c'est pas gagné pour eux
si a pas de vague bleue mais qui est
juste une légère
s'ils ne font que gagner les fameux 23
sièges dont ils ont besoin pour la
majorité
ça reste une petite victoire une grande
victoire ben moi je dirais une petite
défaite en réalité parce que ils ont
besoin d'impulsions ils ont besoin d'un
momentum pour 2020 ils ont besoin s'ils
sont pas capables de s'organiser
d'organiser l'opposition actions dans
les conditions dans lesquelles on est je
sais pas ce que ça va prendre pour
pouvoir déloger de chambre par exemple
20 pour galvaniser les troupes
avec des participations record des
inscriptions record avec une
mobilisation importante avec les femmes
et les minorités qui s'y mettre
s'il n'y arrive pas mais pour moi c'est
davantage une défaite une victoire même
s'ils réussissent à contrôler lâchant
quand on regarde le taux d'approbation
monsieur 3 vous avez bradé sec 41 %
celles qui cherchent à savez s'il est
depuis deux semaines à bruz en 41 45
normalement savez ça a dû amener
bullguard perte de sièges ça ne l'a pas
fait donc trente huit ans afin de
défaire un petit peu la façon qu'on
confond qu'on évalue les campagnes parce
que c'est clair que ça ces deux
dernières semaines il va en prendre
d'ailleurs le crazy déjà commencé vous
avez citerai tous comptables à déployer
pour les 10 des pertes au niveau de la
chambre des représentants il va faire
des gains nouveau du sénat le gouverneur
et qu'on verra son portable dans le
décor
parce que c'est des états d'ailleurs le
réseau américain fox conduite le réseau
train de prédire fait une projection que
les démocrates vont remporter
on ne peut pas dire la sandero en terme
on peut pas savoir répondre à ce titre
aux tournées vendus dans l'oise pays
alors quelle idiotie je pense que la
plupart des gens nous sommes novateurs
les etats-unis disent où étaient les
démocrates durant cette campagne qui est
allé passer il faut là qui compte dans
nos 30 à châteaulin et chaque disque ou
c'est ça que ça prenait la chance qui
démarre quand on fait pire quand ils
sont chanceux qui daignent pull avantage
dans la chambre des représentants s'il
doit s'appliquer mais critiquer son
caractère son personnage comment il est
jamais ils ont touché à renier
effectivement surtout sur la question de
la santé ou est ce qui lui a plu des
fêtes de la sainte chandelle que sympa
on aurait pu dire voilà obama coeur mais
il débat oui christian washington
d'intervenir alesi et est ce que barack
obama était la bonne personne d'ailleurs
pourquoi notation qui ce n'est pas parce
que ecoutez-la sur les problèmes que
vivent
le parti démocrate en ce que vit les
démocrates en ce moment c'est en grande
partie parce que barack obama a beaucoup
beaucoup négligent et le parti démocrate
durant ses huit ans à la maison blanche
est ce qu'on a vu en novembre 2016 c'est
un rejet total de barack obama de ses
politiques aux etats-unis alors le
ramener et espérer gagner provoqué une
vague bleue avec monsieur obama
il ya des gens qu'il aime beaucoup il
est encore oui très populaire mais on
avait l'impression de voir un vieux film
du déjà vu il va falloir vraiment et ça
sera pas facile parce qu'aujourd'hui
comme disait karine c'est une défaite ce
sera une défaite s'il n'y a pas de bacs
bleus ici les démocrates réussissent à
peine à remporter la chambre ce sera
très difficile pour eux de se mobiliser
s'ils ne sont pas capables de le faire
en ce moment
attention pour les prochaines années
christian je vais vous laisser aller
vous devez vous joindre à l'équipe
titrait le journal parce que à la
première chaîne y aura un téléjournal
avec céline galipeau à 22h il remercie
téléjournal de vous avoir laissé venir a
noté mission nous allons peut-être se
reparler après à tout à l'heure
merci christian a tantôt johnny obama
mais nancy pelosi qu'on a vu tout à
l'heure également moi je suis d'accord
avec une science ballack on va rester et
d'après moi l'histoire vous exciter un
bon président il y avait bien tel midi à
gagner de majorité effets des réformes
importantes mais c'est à points bosh est
parti et ce je pense que les gens sont
peut-être concédé madame peloux si c'est
vraiment le code est resté trop
longtemps
c'est une grande dame c'est une les
aides étaient très bonne quantité
présente la chambre alors il n'y a pas
personne qui peut collecter des fonds
pour son parti comme dans ces pôles
aussi mais il y avait il y avait déjà
des représentants qui étaient candidats
ça faisait des candidates et candidats
qui voulait être le plus en tant qu'ils
ne devancent que s'ils gagnent ils
voteront pas pour mon emploi aussi donc
on voyait qu'elle vienne contestation et
me rappelle aussi y tenait ps
s'accrochait et donc sa salle et c'est
ça donnait une cb monsieur à monsieur
tram s'éloigne des jo le niveau et
j'ajouterais quelque chose qui s'est
passé en 1994 c'est loin mais il ya eu
un dénommé new thing richie a fait une
campagne ce qu'est ce qu'ils appelaient
contrat coûtera contrat avec l'amérique
avec un programme qui était qui était
avec la solidarité de tout l'ensemble de
ces jacques aumont a dit tantôt je
penserai de vous
le dit il n'y en avait pas de problème
donc le problème le problème avec les
démocrates
c'est qu'ils n'ont pas un message unis
les parts à leur sortie
oprah winfrey c'est spectaculaire pour
les nouvelles de 6h30
quant à quelqu'un qui en a pâti au poids
qui était l'autre côté de la porte
mais c'est pas de cette façon-là riom
qu'on va avoir une relation et qu'on va
gagner le contrôle des espaces ans que
je suis beaucoup plus loin que ça et en
plus mais je me dis si on suppose aussi
que tu encore chaque jour maintenant
qu'on veut et tout avion gain comme joe
byden parvenu lui aussi pour moi le
problème de forme cyclique
oui j'ai pas mangé je peux pas te dire
ça ne parlait tout à l'heure de
l'importance des femmes
cette fois ci donc est-ce que karim vous
pensez que s'il ya cette petite victoire
ou défaite parce que si ce n'est que
vaine
ce ne sont que 23 sièges qui sont gagnés
le gain minimal au fond c'est que les
femmes auront fait un pas mais pas assez
important encore est ce sens grâce à
elles les grandes gagnantes se seront ce
serait gagnant mais les femmes ne
peuvent pas porter le parti démocrate
sur leurs épaules
évidemment il faut que tous les autres
se mobilisent je sais pas on a un
tableau je sais pas si on peut le
présenter maintenant sur l'avenir des
démocrates
je pense qu'on serait prêt à le
présenter on va me trouver le petit
tableau parce que puisque vous avez
parlé au nom vous a préparé des belles
photos avec des bots non vous allez
faire votre choix
le problème des démocrates c'est qu'ils
sont devant un choix générationnel qui
est déchirant pour eux ou bien faut y
aller avec une valeur sûre même
supplanté par un john non plus non plus
d'accord il est complètement aussi
atypique ans il a détruit l'opposition
jimenez
jeune républicain qui est consenti par
iata valère l'autre côté là aux côtés
des black cats et ou bien on y va avec
par exemple joe biden à qui est souvent
mentionnée comme étant celui d'ailleurs
qui le dit qui lui aurait défini mais ce
soir il est peut-être une lueur d'espoir
je serai pas aussi défaitisme et
connecte toi moi là mais toujours batum
est vraiment au coude à coude
terrasson si jamais le rang bas nous les
présenter rapidement je vous demande de
faire un petit quizz et puis y en a
peut-être d'ailleurs dans cette courte
liste quand même à l'aller si laurent
oui mais d'abord parlons de d'elizabeth
warren qui a été réélu ce qui a été
réélu plus tôt aujourd'hui assez
facilement disons le ce a été très très
rapide au cours de la soirée sin les
plus critiques de tous un peu disons le
depuis quelques années en sud la russe
qui est sénatrice de la californie
madame a aussi questionné prêtre
kavanagh au cours de ses interrogatoires
joe biden ancien vice-président
évidemment beto au rock vous en parlait
il ya un instant brice 1-2 le sénateur
indépendant du vermont
michael bloomberg aussi de bluebird
médias mais aussi ancien maire de new
york et mikko broker qui a aussi été
l'une qui a questionné m 4 nages et
enfin corée bok lui aussi donc on en a
trois ici qui faisait partie du comité
spécial responsable d'approuver la
nomination de cet ancien - l'entrée
rapidement chacun votre choix
cbd lundi matin en sortant du bureau de
vote qu'il prendrait sa décision en
janvier mais qui ne l'annoncera pas
nécessairement on peut ajouter d'autres
noms il ya john kerry qui est un autre
donc ce que moi j'ai quelques contenus
dans trois catégories l'incident a joué
on a line à table comme monsieur baden
madame pour une mesure sérieuse mais je
pense que c'est ce genre de candidat qui
peut battre monsieur trappe il ya des 15
à ce que madame houseman accrocheur mais
je suis beaucoup qui sont intéressants
moi je quelques bobos est ce qu'une
femme peut grâce à des pales de la femme
ce jeu pour manger à la peau tannée
avec toi dans ma tête je trouve qu
est-ce qui sert bien en ce moment je
suis content qu est-ce que ce que
charles et petit à petit on était un
petit peu défaitiste dans le dernier
tour de table
les démocrates la chambre
j'ajuste là aussi dans ce tableau noir
comme beaucoup je suis d'abord les
sénateurs l'étain denis pagé mais lors
des deux autres personnes c'est un
document laisse facilement les deux très
grands prix d'accord partie de mon club
parlé tantôt ils le disent ouvertement
alors les clinton faut pas trop en
mettre sur leurs épaules ok alors qu'on
sait que je suis gardé tout ce que vous
avez à dire on vient après là vous en
droit de faire des pauses et puis offre
des images je pense proposer ce matin
monsieur mansion en direct et on va se
retrouver qui y passent comme démocrate
mais qui avait appuyé la candidature de
monsieur kavanagh pour sauver son siège
juste aubin a tout de suite non écoute
[Musique]
oui râpé pause nous avons un président
des états unis et d'un mental
pathologique est plutôt que de
rassembler le peuple américain ils
tentent de nous diviser
fondée sur la couleur de notre peau
fondée sur d'où nous venons fondée sur
notre religion fondée sur notre genre
fondé sur notre identité sexuelle
brice enders donc qui a été réélu
sénateur indépendant passé démocrates et
indépendants mais il fait partie du
caucus démocrate des résultats alors oui
on fait le tour des résultats il ya un
certain adam qui ont été élus dont on
vous a déjà parlé mais puisque ce sont
des luttes importantes ce soir c'est
important d'y revenir
marsha blackburn du côté des
républicains est élu donc elle devient
sénatrice du tennessee avec 56,9 % des
voix maintenant passons à l'indiana où
de ce côté là c'est aussi le candidat
républicain qui a été élu en fait il a
défait jo dan ly avec 54% des voix
maintenant passons au missouri avec
claire mais casse-cou qui tirent de
l'arrière du côté des démocrates 35,9
pour cent des voix contre joe charlie
qui l'actuel procureur général délégué
de l'état du missouri en avance et
confortable avance 79% des voix avec à
peu près le quart des bulletins de vote
qui ont été dépouillés à 7 heures et les
deux luttes à suivre ce soir la première
c'est le texas
eh bien ça vient encore de changer du
côté du texas monsieur cruz maintenant
en avance avec 50,1 pour cent des voix
bateau au rock à 49,2 % des voix il y à
75% des bulletins qui ont été dépouillés
c'est la lutte la plus noire la plus
serrée de la soirée on termine avec la
floride
là il ya 99% des bulletins de vote qui
ont été dépouillés rick scott est en
très légère avance 50,5 pour cent des
voix c'est l'actuel gouverneur de l'état
bill nelson et est sénateur depuis 2000
il est possiblement en train de piet de
perdre son siège et ghislain mascaux des
nouvelles de guillaume à ce que je sache
aux dernières nouvelles il était
toujours derrière monsieur
synthes amiens alors d'abord une
question de santé est très intéressant
parce que vous avez 2 et a vraiment pas
remettre la floride depuis le temps
qu'on en parle depuis 2006 fait 18 ans
que la fuite sans ces débats les états
pivots gauche absolument et le texte les
états ou valais peut poster tendance est
fort intéressant à ses deux des plus
peuplés était étale peu plus quand même
des états unis et ces deux états qui
sont déterminants pour les courses
électorales présidentielles ou de
mi-mandat et regarder quand vous voyez
la carte électorale rouge et bleu de
comment se distribuent les comptes et
les districts rouge et bleu vous voyez
qu'il ya vraiment un affrontement entre
les villes principalement qui sont
bleues démocrates et la campagne et les
régions rurales les régions plus
banlieusards de m
démocrate donc et républicaine au sens
vrai de ces états là donc c'est del très
très très serré à finir dans ces deux
états et selon la projection d'un réseau
américain madame occasion cortès à new
york serait élu à 29 ans donc la plus
jeune elle fait l'histoire d'une jeune
femme qui a pris par surprise manière du
chemin à l'élite du parti démocrate elle
est très très associée à la gauche
travailleuses éléments de demain
correction chaussures baraka le
mouvement qui était mis sur pied à
partir de bornes isound venu avec un
nombre tout est effectivement et
oublient de se présenter au sein du
parti démocrate parce que dans les
primaires c'est les démocrates et
républicains qui contrôlent le système
qui contrôle le gouvernement ce n'est
pas l'indépendance mais il est
intéressant de voir que cette jeune
femme fait partie de l'histoire à 29 ans
etb a fait plus de force de diaboliser
ces gens là parce que dans un dernier
discours c'est la gauche socialiste
il mise beaucoup sur la peur de ces gens
de la commission du même chose quand
qu'on disait qu'elle présenterait un pic
effectivement être une socialiste madame
parisien dit ça existe pas les
socialistes oui vous à cali l'histoire
présente
c'est une belle génération tout à
l'heure on sait justement je pense que
c'est c'est justement à voir - symbole
et cette nouvelle génération qui monte
une génération de femmes une génération
de gens qui proviennent des minorités
ethniques qui ont un message particulier
qui ont un message un peu à contre
courant de ce qu'on entend qu'ils
sortent aussi de l'establishment via le
fait elle a fait beaucoup jaser sur une
vidéo qui a été faite au moment de sa
primaire et voilà on va la voir la
prochaine dans le métro a pas changé a
je pense on va d'abord ce boulot ou à
changer ses souliers plats pour des
talons ou ça vous fait jaser mais que
c'était c'était virale cette salle
permet de parler des hispanophones de
latinos de leur vote
ils sont généralement acquis aux
démocrates
oui et il faut encore qu'ils aillent
voter c'est toujours l'enjeu à chaque
fois qu'on parle de ces minorités
visibles ou du vote c'est un vote
déterminant on va parler peut-être un
peu plus tard très tard je sais pas en
soirée par exemple de l'arizona
c'est un vote déterminant pour l'arizona
pour savoir laquelle par exemple moi je
suis le sénat des deux sénatrices ou
candidate au sénat sera élu il l'est
également au texas puisque le texas sera
majoritairement hispanique très très
très bientôt la californie les déjà le
nouveau mexique les déjà largement
l'arizona l'est aussi donc c'est un vote
fondamental le nevada voilà où se trame
en a assez des hispanophones et des
idées
latino 4 c voire quand tu vois le
caravanier visage a écrit d'un problème
une crise oui mais il polarise le vote
le vote hispanique évidemment contre lui
quoiqu'il n'y a pas que cet enjeu là il
y en a d'autres aussi surveiller le
nevada ça va être des nouvelles petites
nouvelles le gouverneur jared polis il
est où des faits des prêts pourris mène
au colorado utilise son choix alors le
premier gouverneur ouvertement
homosexuel ça paraît bizarre ici
d'évoquer des caractéristiques comme
celle-là au canada alors qu'on a le
mariage pour tous depuis tellement
longtemps qu'on en ouverture mais il est
aux états unis et quelques jours oui et
je pense que oui la classe iia sujet qui
faisait qu'il ressuscitera qui était
très populaire qui était john ray cooper
qui va peut-être être une autre de nous
puisque notre ville un bon baromètre
pour le cacao - peut-être un jour là la
vice-présidence et donc le camp d'ados
la lizonne en tous cas que schaaf existe
c'est un indice que le vote hispanique
est important il y autant que c'est une
question de génération est plus âgé plus
consommateurs aller plus vers les
publicains et un élément qu'il faut
faire il faut pas perdre de vue
peut-être va sauver les meubles ce soir
au pub sauver les meubles se garder ces
dames dont il a baissé n'appuie pas
d'avoir une vague tellement immense où
zhou un samedi la plus à même s'ils
votent tout excès c'est à cause de fake
nous ça comme celui de la façon des
coûts ce qui était décrit wi fi des lois
qui était décrit par fabrice un lieu
celle des clips à mal et à long terme
est ce que le parti depuis qui va voir
la coalition dans cinq dix ans qui va
leur donner c'est la banque et sa
question
puis au moment conçu par puis c'est toi
qui disais que il ya qu'est ce qu'on
appelle en anglais de brands america le
pays d'ici 2050 va être majeur et
tellement nombre et donc tout le
discours de monsieur trame des dernières
semaines vont être dépassés
graduellement va être dépassé
il est le public aimerait être père
damnation panneaux font beaucoup
impliqués dans le processus électoral
mais globalement c'est exactement mais
une un facteur qu'on oublie aussi c'est
que dans le nouveau du mouvement
syndical aux etats unis c'est les
hispanophones
c'est incroyable particulièrement dans
les états qu'il ya au filet la régionale
sud de la californie et le nevada au
niveau de l'installation industries de
services le contrôle du mouvement sont
entamées diop sy de mouvement syndical
très progressiste d'ailleurs que madame
en côte est allé chercher l'appui des
syndicats
donc quelque chose qui se passe parmi sa
communauté la queue au niveau des
africains-américains kouroublis en 2016
blake nill et les publics et la gestion
muet le procès de la floride devrait
vous donner l'information parce qu'elle
est référendum un chacun dans plusieurs
états différents il ya des différends
afin d'amener avait une question
importante au en floride
c'était le droit de vote qui avaient été
supprimés pour les personnes oda au
dossier criminel perdu perdre son droit
de vote est ville pour disons un vol à
l'étalagé quelque chose comme ça le
référendum donne raison
aux personnes qui ont un dossier
criminel le gang l'endroit de voix et on
oublie souvent que c'est beaucoup de
personnes c'est 6 millions d'américains
qui ont perdu leur droit de vote en
raison d'un dossier criminel et 1 sur 13
est afro-américain alors encore une fois
on a une explication se renfermer sur un
million et demi c'est ça donc c'est
s'est énormément de gens qui perdent ce
droit de vote là alors ya un paquet de
pâques et des toges exagère un peu une
dizaine d'états qui avait cette question
là sur leur bulletin de vote aujourd'hui
leur nature valley une brève pause et
d'autres résultats à venir d'autres
choses passionnantes entendre de votre
part merci d'être là on va retrouver
christian après la pause et on va pour
se mettre au pas les latitudes human
genome
[Applaudissements]
novare i à zaghouan nos bords y écouter
personne a déjà gagné dans un état où le
président dans une élection présidente
avait gagné par 42 points et que la
partie adverse gagne ce n'est jamais
pensé on écrit l'histoire ce soir
[Musique]
il est 22 heures
on s'attendait de journée historique aux
états unis c'est une soirée électorale
très serré mais vraiment très serrée à
laquelle on assiste
nous poursuivons donc cette couverture
spéciale des élections de mi mandat qui
prendra un caractère historique
à deux ans d'une élection présidentielle
ou pour monsieur crohas me prépare déjà
sa réélection et le réseau qui lutterait
fabre à fox news annonce déjà que les
démocrates prendrait le contrôle de la
chambre des représentants sans trois
démocrates sont présentement il eu ou en
avance contre 99 républicain il devait
regagner 23 sièges donc protège la
majorité de 218 sièges sur les 435 pour
prendre ce contrôle et les sondages
prévoyaient un écart assez large de
gains possibles on verra si ça se
réalise au sénat par ailleurs 45 sièges
sont présentement acquis aux
républicains contre 38 au démocrate et
on pense que le
les républicains vont garder le contrôle
de la chambre haute le sénat mais
revenons brièvement au québec c'est une
journée triste une journée de deuil
notamment pour la grande famille
souverainiste et pour la famille
également de lancer premiers bugs
sonores landry aujourd'hui c'était à
l'âge de 81 ans dans cette nouvelle a
provoqué une avalanche de réactions
quasi unanime de tous les horizons
politiques on vous en présente
quelques-unes de ses réactions
donc en cas audi ag pestait le conte la
transaction de rooney c'est à quelqu'un
alors il y avait ce don carlos qui est
québécois doit rester québécois on doit
reconnaître d'abord aujourd'hui son
dévouement envers sa communauté
qui nous laisse énormément c'est
monsieur landry oui on dire grands
québécois mais un patriote comme il se
nommait lui-même il y avait le québec
tatoué sur le coeur puis le plus chaud
sur ce qu'on peut retenir mais je pense
que jamais de l'enfance sur la vision
qui a eu pour toute l'industrie créative
la l'industrie technologique également
numérique c'est une grande perte
le seul indice était vraiment un
militant indépendantiste un premier
ministre ou et c'est pour le québec
puis c'est vraiment désolant c'est
quelqu'un qui compte une même après
avoir été premier ministre me dit tu es
quelqu'un comme société éminemment
précieux pour le moment des pendentifs
et monsieur landry y aura des
funérailles d'état comme il se doit pour
tous les anciens premiers ministres du
québec c'est la plus haute distinction
en fait le grand dommage qu'ils puissent
être rendus
un ancien premier ministre les détails
sont à venir bien évidemment et les
drapeaux sont en berne à l'assemblée
nationale je retrouve maintenant à
washington christian latreille et en
floride
raphaël bouvier au clair et christian
les messieurs 3 mai toujours à la maison
blanche est ce que c'est manifester est
ce que comment se passe ce soir est
d'après vous bon on ne sait pas pour
l'instant il est calme ce qui sera
intéressant de suivre au cours des
prochains jours c'est que si les
démocrates réussissent à obtenir une
majorité assez significative en chambre
ça serait la façon qu'il travaillera
avec les démocrates du sénat monsieur
monsieur de chambre c'est pas vraiment
un républicain
il aussi des idées plus libérale plus
plus à gauche mais ce serait intéressant
de voir l'interaction entre le président
à la nouvelle majorité en chambre
madame pelossi qui va probablement
redevenir leader a dit il n'est pas
question d'entamer une procédure de
destitution pour l'instant contre contre
monsieur choï cependant ce que les
démocrates vont vouloir faire est assez
rapidement c'est tenter d'obtenir les
états financiers et les rapports d'impôt
demeure un très très très rapidement et
ça ils l'ont promis parce que monsieur
jobs avait promis justement de les
rendre public ce qu'il n'a jamais fait
alors le fait que ce soir les démocrates
eux reprennent la chambre peu importe
leur majorité
le pourcentage est bien ça ne ferait pas
dérailler le projet politique de
monsieur choï
au contraire tout son projet
d'infrastructure il va peut-être rayer
le réaliser avec les démocrates et avec
le sénat encore républicains il va
pouvoir continuer de nommer des juges
conservateurs et faire en sorte que les
cours fédérales les cours d'appel à
travers le pays et la cour suprême
demeure conservatrice c'est bien alors
raphaël maintenant à miami la soirée se
déroule dans un climat de suspense et un
suspense quand même encore en floride
non
voici aussi on avait voulu un scénario
serré on aurait vraiment pas plus
l'espérer et je vous parle de deux
courses en particulier la course au
poste de gouverneur et celle au poste de
sénateur l'avantagé est en ce moment
dans les deux cas aux républicains c'est
une marche est très très minces mais la
plupart des votes ont été complètes
comptabilisées alors moi je me trouve en
ce moment dans un rassemblement
démocrate à miami et on regarde ça avec
beaucoup d'attention les gens attendent
de voir attendre que les grands réseaux
américains décident est attribué la
victoire non aux républicains alors on
surveille ça faut dire quand même qu'il
ya eu énormément d'espoir qui ont été
fondés sur la course démocrate au poste
de gouverneur c'est un flou qui l'homme
qui est le candidat s'il était élu ce
soir il deviendrait le premier
afro-américain à la tête de la floride
et ça fait très longtemps aussi qu'il
n'y a pas eu de démocrates qui a occupé
ce poste de gouverneur en floride ont
conservé cette près en même temps il ya
des petites victoires quand même qu'ils
ont été célébrés ici dans la région de
miami il ya deux gains qui ont été
effectuées à la chambre des
représentants dans le district dans
lequel je me trouve le 27e strict mais
aussi le 26e et un peu plus au sud
devant l'extrême sud de la floride
ce sont des circonscriptions qui était
représenté par les puritains jusqu'à ce
soir donc ça fait partie de ces gains
qui ont déjà été comptés vous écoutez un
démocrate à l'échelle nationale pour la
chambre des représentants
merci à raphaël alors réalisant alors
réaction de votre côté une question
purement technique et si on est habitué
des dépouillements judiciaires dans ce
qu'on appelle les recomptages dans des
luttes aussi série comme celle là qu'est
ce que est ce que sera le résultat
incertain ce que ça prend des jours des
mois avant deux ans qu'est ce qui arrive
il ya un seuil minimum au delà duquel il
la procédure est automatique
la plupart des états et ça arrive plutôt
fréquemment et on a déjà vu naître un
noyau par exemple en 2000 en 2004
mémoire est bonne il y avait eu un très
long recomptage dans la plupart des
districts alors ça arrive souvent
il ya une coupe d'étagés malheureusement
je propose et je me suis dit qu'ils ont
et ceux de renault c'est grâce à un
troisième candidat je pense madame et
brahms et candidat sel n'est pas 50 % il
ya un deuxième tour à neuf c'est un
deuxième tour c'est ça c'est assez rare
où ça s'est répandue johnny je pense
qu'il est un homme je peux passer le
plus célèbre évidemment c'est celle de
bord gauche qui était une cimenterie
j'ai des sens mais c'est un coup ce pub
derrière qu'il a tranché suivi de la
comptage puis finalement ils ont arrêté
le comptage parce que je crois qu'elle
est pas qu on voulait que tout les
comtés soit les décompter soit
rentabilisée en va donc ça aurait
peut-être d'avoir les quelques heures ce
soir puisque ce toit floride son arrêt
sur la lancée de christian c'est une
question fort important de savoir
l'impact
c'est très concret d'une victoire pour
les démocrates de la chambre des
représentants parlent beaucoup d'
enquête d'investigation dota que il a
réussi le sucre ans pendant la campagne
à faire passer comme étant des mensonges
c'est les fameuses collusion dans quatre
muller au grand complet avec les mineurs
de se changer un caractère spécial on
n'avait pas beaucoup parler dans la
campagne parce que les victoires
démocrates s'ils se concrétisent à la
chambre des représentants sauve la peau
de justement le
on enquête clairement il va y avoir
beaucoup beaucoup de polarisation
politique et enfin moi je pense que le
jeu politique risque d'être assez bloqué
pendant 2 1 et surtout ses enquêtes ces
comparutions de tous les conseillers des
gens qui sont autour d'eux dans leurs
crimes devant les comités de la chambre
des représentants parce que concrètement
autres questions techniques ce que ça
fait en fait vraiment le contrôle d'une
chambre c'est contrôler les comités
c'est les comités qui après soir j'ai vu
durant la comparution du juge
cabanas voulu gc les comités qui font le
travail vraiment de contrôler l'agenda
législatif alors savoir donner une
énorme réseau nommé donald l'idée
d'avoir on a beaucoup vanté la
démocratie américaine en disant poids
contrepoids les pères fondateurs ont
voulu ça donc est ce c'est possible
notre coq que les démocrates soit au
moins donner un contrepoids au pouvoir
du président actuel
hervé décision c'est quand c'est tout à
fait ça on voit vraiment en force le
poids contre eux pour particulièrement
avec un président et amélie des états
unis qui voit la gouvernance comme
l'autoritarisme
on revient un certain poids contrepoids
qui est la base de la démocratie
américaine
la question du consensus ça veut pas
dire qu un président un président qui
comprend la politique peu capable de
convaincre certains démocrates de voter
xi 18 15 mai dans le cadre d'autres en
presqu'île
cette attitude là ouais ce qu'il a
prouvé dans le passé et a même pas
capable de passer sont pleins ou du goût
de la santé le tram caire puis
convaincre les gens mais de son propre
parti qui définit les démocrates comme
des bandits
dadaux avait demandé ma demande de
meubles
mafia vous savez pas que le tweak qui va
sur celles à 4 heures du matin donc
c'est ça la fait avec toi + moi je pense
que que le pouvoir d' enquête c'est pas
négliger puis les enquêtes sur ces
impôts ceci ici se peut me sinon ils
s'appliquent loin térésa tous à paris
une webcam australie plus loin que mon
coeur est empli de somme
il ya quand même dix ans des terrains
d'entente possible sur d'agressivité
contre la chine s'est claqué deux
républiques des démocrates qui peuplent
appuyer sur ça et sur les dépenses que
je pense que non mentionnés ici tantôt
ça ses claques silva le programme d'être
sur son mur d'abord son fameux mur mais
le mudam on espère moins fines et leurs
produits la peau nue pic de toute façon
y'a encore dit qu'elle est criarde
engager des mois qu'on travaille là je
vais mieux street show et si on est
optimiste que les démocrates peuvent
être avec moi je pense qu'il va y avoir
une bataille d'une guerre civile
politique entre les démocrates et est
d'ores et déjà commencé parce qu'au fond
regarder dans un an on voit déjà
quasiment en train de commencer à penser
à qu'il faut se présenter aux primaires
c'est une minute qu'on va donner à dans
l'autre chambre quelconque crédit pour
obtenir quoi que ce soit dans ses
planches de rezé et dernière chose
devrait voir de dépenses du budget les
démocrates vont bloquer ou lors notre
homme soit deux cents de ces projets le
pouvoir de départ comme on dit en
anglais de la chambre des représentants
mais puissant on hamm est en même temps
monsieur 30 je me demandais en début
d'émission le temps passe vite lui va se
trouver un nouvel ennemi la chambre des
représentants même s'ils contrôlent les
deux chambres depuis deux ans et vous y
regardez les démocrates cd bandits
on entend encore dans les assemblées
locales aux pourparlers dans les
vitrines
alors cnn dégueulasse cette question
d'un ennemi alors il va justifier dont
quatre caisses kelly se tait de couze
tard ou pis donc c'est avec 30
qu'est-ce qu'ils y faut en prendre et en
laisser les mensonges et là même où ça
c'est moi moi je pense que les
démocrates auraient les halles est quand
même intérêt je compare qu'est ce que je
faisais la guerre civile mais ils ont
été elles est d'avoir quand même liman
ainsi le problème est que les démocrates
pour le dit tantôt et ont pas de plan de
commandes compte comment gouverner c'est
quoi elle salazie et si il va juste
bloquer ou fait l'impeachment monsieur
mais feront pas parce que le scénario
d'un marteau mais s'ils font juste la
question des blacks est débloqué je
pense qu'il va voir un dessin et de
peinture et faites la même chose il
faudrait même changé bompard de l'élan
pour 2020 et c'est là qu'il faut qu'ils
manquent des gens s'ils ont la majorité
à la chambre comment qui peuvent
gouverner donc démontrer la population
lui qu'une alternative de gouvernement
ce maîtrise des concepts exactement
quito sein de la chambre des
représentants qui pas nécessairement la
maison blanche
moi je pense vous le faites bien
attention et démocrates parce que pour
russell est là pour 2020 candidats et
tous les espoirs pour être porté son
veto karine mais selon nbc en projette
l'élection monsieur couderc est assez
serré un goût très près ce qu'il advient
de monsieur roux de faibles marges
il reste dans les présidentiables pays
reste très intéressant parce que d'une
part et à mobiliser les jeunes mobilise
des femmes les minorités
honnêtement c'est le fait qu'ici
la définition de reste une défaite mais
le fait demeure c'est que je passe qui
va très très intéressant c'est le
prototype 2 avec ma thèse qu'est ce
qu'on souhaite ni la passion des
délations donc est à surveiller tout ce
que vous allez allez allez mon voleur a
alors donnons quelques quelques
résultats commence avec le tapotage
[Rires]
reprenons nos esprits et revend à ses
résultats parlant du dakota du nord
puisque on s'attendait en début de
soirée à ce que madame attias du parti
démocrate perdre son siège mais c'est
fait et c'est effectivement le cas
son opposant kevin promu a été élu je
rappelle que madame red cabs avait été
très très était pas très très populaire
dans son étal avait à peu près trente
sept pour cent d'appui à la toute fin
surtout parce qu'il ya eu une période
d'hésitation elle se demandait si oui ou
non elle allait voter en faveur de la
nomination de brad cabana
elle a décidé de ne pas le faire mais
peut-être que le fait d'avoir hésité un
peu ça aura fait tourner quelques
électeurs démocrates contre elle je vous
dis ça bien humblement mais donc madame
à cames qui perd son siège au sénat
on en sort on enchaîne tout de suite
avec la floride là ce n'est toujours pas
réglé mais ça devient de plus en plus
clair que rick scott a à peu près les
chances de l'emporter avec écoute et on
est prêt la 50,3 % des voix contre bill
nelson avec 49,7 % il ya à peu près 99%
des bulletins qui ont été dépouillés
possible qu'ils aient un recomptage de
ce côté là tellement c'est serré du côté
de la floride
on s'en va au texas maintenant vous en
parlait il ya un instant il ya une
source donc cms nbc qu'il donne monsieur
kraus gagnant cnn et fox news ne se sont
toujours pas prononcé quant à la
victoire de tête cloud la raison pour
laquelle vous ne voyez pas ici de
petites bandes élus et selon les
derniers résultats telle clause à 50,7 %
des voix monsieur roch en à 48,6 y en a
qui vous diront
même si monsieur roch a perdu cette
lutte il a quand même été l'un des
grands gagnants démocrate de la soirée
et je vous amène finalement dans deux
luttes à la chambre des représentants on
en parle en début de soirée il y avait
deux américano musulmanes qui pouvait
devenir les deux premières au sénat et
bien c'est fait les deux ont été élus
c'est le cas de ilan au mas et c'est le
cas aussi de l'autre candidate rachid la
table au michigan des résultats par
rapport à la chambre des représentants
justement les démocrates doivent encore
gagner 11 sièges
s'il veut s'ils veulent obtenir la
majorité je vous rappelle que selon fox
news c'est déjà chose réglée les
démocrates obtiendront donc la majorité
à la chambre des représentants
si on se fie à ce réseau qui
habituellement on va dire n'est pas trop
trop en faveur des démons merci beaucoup
le rang alors c'est intéressant de voir
ce que je vais vous habille son ego et
l'arizona ça commence à être intéressant
aussi parce qu'on revit le scénario de
floride et du texas que nous a présenté
laurent et ben les deux candidates mecs
ali et madame cinéma son cinéma sont à
égalité à peu près 1% ou moins 2 et là
c'est 50% de tous non seulement attendu
que l'arizona sûr mais aussi chaud entre
démocrates et républicains donc en john
parole de fo regarde un peu l'avenir
ça aussi c'est un est intéressant qui
annonce des changements démographiques
et politiques importants oui les blés
sondages aussi parce qu'elles vont payer
certains hackers peuvent par exemple
monsieur il y avait encore ces dernières
heures un écart de 7 % on le mettait
perdant avec 7 % d'écart et les autres
il y avait eu c'était le débat plaidant
la marge d'erreur je vais vous amener
sur madame claire mais madame ou membre
de l'aed est une ligne à detroit mais
c'est une palestinienne d'origine madame
omar une somalienne qui a passé quatre
ans dans les camps de réfugiés au kenya
donc c'est madame de thèbes avait une
famille de 14 enfants
c'est des jeunes fans qui sont on la
voit le madame plein je te vends dans un
reportage qui avait été présenté sur
elle elle est d'une famille de 14
enfants donc cette nouvelle génération
des femmes qui veulent s'engager
celui qui vient du 6 mai démocrate je
pensais très critique de la position de
sa va compléter un peu le tableau de
magra fiq aussi parce que quand on
regarde dans l'ensemble du congrès il ya
que deux hommes qui sont musulmans mais
deux élus musulmans aux etats-unis
malgré le froid 4 à ce moment là et
l'ado de vin plus cette femme-là
démocrate amérindienne charlie davies de
15 à ce qui était lui également
oui donc alors une dose est intéressante
qui perd ses invectives manche et
finalement un message qu'on envoie ya
dans notre homme que l'amérique est
toujours diversifié c'est la musique
c'est comme ça que j'étais venu on
grandit c'est l'immigration qui
construit des questions identitaires qui
voit les mêmes chiffres que toi pendant
20 ans et ben partie des blancs
essentiellement vois les choses comme
elles sont le parti de donald trump et
le parti démocrate c'est le parti arc en
ciel c'est à dire c'est vraiment le
parti qui où il ya plusieurs couleurs
dans tous les sens du terme politique et
démographique qui se ramasse au sein du
parti et je dirais c'est la raison
fondamentale pour laquelle le parti
républicain a développé un message assez
cohérent et unifié
même si on peut ne pas l'aimer et le
parti démocrate de la difficulté à
synthétiser à trouver une voie unique
qui fasse consensus parce que vous avez
une un peu plus centristes de droite
pragmatique une aile de gauche un peu
plus on va dire gentiment socialistes
qui ont des agendas différents dans ce
parti là a lancé sur chez beaucoup plus
difficiles pour les démocrates et la
seule façon pour les démocrates toujours
de surgir c'est d'avoir la bonne
personne le bon candidat présidentiel au
bon moment
chez moi pourquoi ça prend une bonne
personne avec un certain profil pour le
démocrate mais que pour 35 points c'est
un homme dont le don là personnellement
parce que les gens sont partis plus
homogène et et je pense que l'erreur
qu'on fait depuis 2000 15
essentiellement c'est de mettre autant
d'emphase sur la rhétorique
effectivement le fait pour de bonnes
raisons c'est à dire que je vais qu'il
fut oui mais mais mais de s'attaquer
toujours à ça de crise qui toujours soin
de souligner toujours ça est ce que ça
change rien des baisers mais ce n'est
pas la responsabilité mais brochette une
pause par exemple oui qui frôle les 6000
dénonciation de mensonges de prendre
mais de dire cela change absolument rien
mais c'est la responsabilit stick de
faire les ouvertures bien sûr honnête
c'est dur tendu motion pause ont
augmenté leurs abonnés mais pour les
pour les gens pour les citoyens pour les
électeurs à changer ça change absolument
rien parce qu'en principe cette
protection en garde qu est ce que tu
chantes pas réaliser il faut voir au
début de la campagne de 2005 mais
marrant lily famille des bols 2015 2016
le parti n'était pas le pâtis de dans
mon coeur même du public et le bouillet
qui en a fait son parti les libertariens
droite la droite religieuse les états
unis et tous ces gens là avec le
populisme avec l'accueil fut des sceaux
c'est devenu son parti à table parce que
ses claques que oui vous avez raison
cela jacking par trump
mais il a passé le week-end beaucoup
plus diversifiée qu'on attribue il reste
quand même que quand monsieur trump se
déclarer nationalisme qui n'a pas la
même connotation que ceux déclarés
nationaliste au québec maintenant la
même chose ses clacs a rendu des gens
très inconfortable donc ce n'est pas le
problème
on sait ce qu'il faisait ce soir il ya
ce tram peut réclamer une certaine
victoire la chandelle le sénat ils
disent de perdre comme semble l'indiquer
la chambre des représentants mais
l'arrivée de ces jeunes dont les deux
femmes que vous avez mentionné tantôt la
lutte corps sikhs monsieur roch a amené
et le fait qu'il ya une certaine
diversité le le gouverneur guy au
colorado
ça démontre que il ya le parti
républicain
un niveau du niveau de dissidence qui
veut peut-être pas dans le caucus en ce
moment mais il est d'aller télévision
comme pour regarder depuis deux ans et
bill kristol et david brooks bret
stephens belga c'est pas que c'est comme
ça qu'on s'est dit gestion quand même si
elles seront plus à l'intérieur si
j'allais y ont quand même ne les a pas
de toute façon on va vers une tension
dans ce parti s'il est rapatrié une
dissidence qui est ce moment c'est à
dire pas grand chose pour les ex mym à
l'extérieur elle a gardé votre opinion
on va repartir à minuit alors la prose
regard des jeux pour de la part le
retour alors messieurs rester avec nous
on s'en va à la pause
le gouverneur républicain s'exerce greg
abbott a été facilement élu détient
présentement et d'avant de 750 voix on
l'écoutera épingle merci août ex entre
août exsangue de m'avoir ribul et poste
de gouvreneur gouverneur du meilleur
état de l'union je ne fais jamais arrêté
de me battre ont vu et vous familles à
mesure que nous continuons de faire
texas le premier état de l'union
[Musique]
et oui j'espère chauffer alors le sort
en est jeté
pour les deux chambres les projections
confirmation de gagnant c'est fait
laurent oui voilà alors ce qu'on peut
vous dire c'est que effectivement le
sénat va rester dans les mains des
républicains pour les deux prochaines
années
par contre du côté de la chambre des
représentants eh bien on peut vous
confirmer qu'il y aura un changement ce
sont les démocrates qui contrôlent la
chambre des représentants
jusqu'en 2020 et je peux par ailleurs
vous dire que ted cruz restera sénateur
du texas veto au rock n'a pas réussi son
pari
du côté du texas même si c'est passé
très très près tête rousse dans porte
avec une très très mince majorité
il avait toute une pente raide à
remonter laurent et avait sept points
d'écart selon dansant du sondage merci
beaucoup à laurent
à tout à l'heure je dois maintenant
alexandre coup sûr gagnant elle est
professeur de sciences politiques à
l'université rio grande et valeo tu
exerces certains réseaux projette la
victoire dont un s'est fait de tête cruz
bonsoir madame coup sûr gagnant alors
êtes-vous c'est d'abord une première
réaction à ce résultat
êtes vous étonné on savait pas jusqu'à
la dernière minute si heureux que cruise
allait l'emporter les sondages mais
quelques points d'avancé comme vous
l'avez mentionné à cruz
or occupent une bonne campagne 70
millions de dollars qui avait ramassé
ans dont deux sources vraiment du lierse
une campagne originale aussi visité tous
les comtés beaucoup misé sur le vote des
latinos donc je pense que jusqu'à la
toute fin il y avait pu y avait des
chances de gagner la date je crois qu'on
a quelques à 30% des votes qui ont été
comptés mais il reste plusieurs
districts ruraux qui ont toujours pas
été content et puis ces districts en
sapant ce qui à cause d'un cruz devrait
l'emporter avec quelques 45.5 points
avant ce qui est quand même un avantage
beaucoup moins importante côté
républicain que l' avantage que trump
avait qui étaient déjà plus faibles
qu'eux
habitude pour les républicains trump
avait gagné avec neuf points d'avancé ce
qui était sûr hillary clinton donc
c'était les républicains étaient moins
en force au secteur à la dernière
élection puis avec la marge entre
creuser rourke c'est tout c'est encore
amenuisés en étant vous même votre xav
vous avez pu suivre de plus près que
nous au forceps cette campagne là il
reste qu est ce qui a séduit chez au
rock dans la population vous avez parlé
du vote latino bien sûr mais cake à part
son financement très original je pense
qu'ils refusaient le financement des
fameux super pack ou déjà des gros
donateurs l'a donc une campagne de
proximité qu'est ce que ça veut dire
pour vous oui j'avais aimé un puck en
deux puisque si j'avais jamais vu autant
d' affiches électorales pour un candidat
à un poste fédéral puis passe nationale
depuis l'aube et des affiches beto pour
le sénat était vraiment à me présente
j'ai hâte de voir les taux de
participation des électeurs latinos des
jeunes
je pense qu'il est allé il reste à aller
chercher beaucoup plus d'électeurs coq
auparavant une participation de toute
façon est plus élevé qu'auparavant en
partie à cause de tromper mais je pense
que on va dans les prochains dans les
prochains jours on va voir que bateaux
auront réussi à faire augmenter de façon
importante le vote le vote des bâtiments
puis des jeunes des jeunes au texas mais
je lui donnais mon ordi note euros qui
peut-être aller avec une campagne qui
était un petit peu trop à gauche un
petit peu trop radicales pour pour
l'autre exerce qui demeure un état
républicain
il était par exemple pour l'abolition de
lagence d'immigration qui d ailleurs de
déporter les migrants ice notamment oui
évidemment pour étendre également les
soins de santé et s'assurer de son
application
est ce que pour vous cette élection est
avec l'interprétation qu'on peut faire
bon le sénat qui l'est républicain
conserve les démocrates qui font des
gains donc pour le contrôle de la
chambre des représentants qu'est ce que
ça vous dise comme comme c'est par
référendum sur 30 visite guidée à ce à
quoi on s'attendait
la polarisation des la police la
policière la polarisation de l'électeur
américain
un résultat qui m'a beaucoup
impressionné ce soir c'est la délégation
du texas à la chambre des représentants
donc la chambre des représentants
devenir démocrates mais il est exact
doit avoir quelques 15 ou 16 sièges
démocrates à la chambre des
représentants s'est beaucoup ne
s'attendait pas à ça tout les loteries
qui était serré et exerce à date le
dollar à houston district près d'alès
près du stand en salle antonio puis el
paso ces districts à sont tous alliés
démocrates donc si vous regardez la
carte du teaser pour la délégation à la
chambre des représentants
c'est beaucoup plus bleu c'est beaucoup
plus démocratique auparavant avant on
disait qu'on avait des bleuets dans
quelques démocrates le parmi les
républicains vraiment républicaine mais
là c'est pas mal bleu qu'est ce que vous
pensez que ça annonce pour 2020 alors
parce que c'est vrai que le taux de
participation à la fois au vote par
anticipation était très élevé que la
scission va on verra les chiffres de
participation ce que ça envoie comme
message de mobilisation notamment chez
les plus jeunes et les latinos mais ce
que c'est qu'est-ce que ça envoie pour
vous comme message pour 2020 parce que
demain matin on va déjà parlé de
l'élection présidentielle qui s'en vient
en 2000
tout est sur la table ce qu'ils soient
tard après l'élection très bien géré
assez de faire des prédictions plus de
s'avancer haute exerce pour la première
fois on a deux femmes latina qui sont
élus au congrès est-ce qu'à bord et
garcia je crois donc que j'ai on n'avait
jamais eu de femme latine ans qui avait
été élu à la chambre des représentants
ou pour des mandats complet tant que
juge pas je pense que le la la
population latino et exhortent la
population latino la teneur exacte doit
continuer d'avoir une importance de plus
en plus importante dans les élections
mais ça va être de voir à quel point les
latinos vont finalement sortir pour pour
aller voir si le mans les prochaines
élections si c'était juste et l excès
élections si parce qu'ils se trompent
les avais trop polarisé les latinos du
d'exar demeure quand même plus
républicain que dans d'autres que dans
d'autres états où il ya plusieurs latino
donc vraiment la population latino du
texas va jouer beaucoup pour pour les
élections de mai alexandre rousseau
gagnon merci d'avoir été
avec nous bonne fin de soirée électorale
et reste évidemment d'autres résultats à
11h heure de laisser d'autres bulletins
d'autres états donc où les bureaux de
vote vont fermer on attend avec
impatience évidemment les résultats de
laquelle ils fournissent aux sapins est
clos alors merci beaucoup à la prochaine
merci alors de la mission s'en va à la
brève pause et on revient il isabelle
vallée qui est au bout alors ça prend
une pause elisabeth bonsoir à bonsoir
elizabeth
bonsoir alors évidemment vous avez une
soirée bien occupé avec vos experts vos
analystes vont observateur passionné de
la chose politique
êtes vous déçu à ce moment c'est des
résultats bien que c'est une victoire
des représentants pour la chine pour la
chambre des représentants mais une
victoire des démocrates donc et pour les
républicains le conserve le pouvoir la
majorité au sénat qu'est ce que ça vous
dit mais c'est très conforme à ce qu'on
pensait ce qui était annoncé pour une
fois les sondeurs ont mis dans le mille
peut-être un peu déçu à l'instar
d'alexandre couture gagnant du résultat
au texas bien que le texas où un état
très républicain on aurait pu imaginer
que beto des taureaux qui serait allé
chercher peut-être plus encore l'âme du
texas on voit que le long de la
frontière l'aspiration peut être un
changement de tendance était était
perceptible
le vote des latinos elle en parlait
alexandre couture gagnon de voir ça un
peu ce que ça va avoir donné parce que
pour la première fois ci on peut avoir
une mobilisation de l'électorat latino
ça pourrait être quelque chose de très
important
il faut savoir que les abords du patron
avait prévu de faire des démonstrations
de force à la frontière aujourd'hui
avait prévu de montrer de monter des
opérations de contention de la foule
donc il y avait une très grande
politique politisation de la frontière
et une victoire de beto o'rourke aurait
peut-être été intéressant pour un peu
inversé la tendance peut-être 2d -
sentiment que on et la militarisation
est inéluctable donc c'est peut-être sur
des courses très précise à dire est
qu'un possible parce que sa prise de
position sur quelles valeurs a été
une peine d'une sanction en quelque
sorte donc c'est une femme qui a été
sanctionné en raison de sa prise de
position en partie il ya quelques
courses ici et là qui sont plus
décevantes mais globalement ça reste
conforme aux résultats qu'on attendait
maintenant cette victoire des démocrates
à la chambre des représentants s'annonce
quoi pour vous en termes de réalisation
de projets tout à l'heure les invités
ici 10 dans le fond monsieur trump ne le
fera pas son mur les représentants les
démocrates prennent un peu le contrôle
du budget un nouveau la chambre des
représentants vous la spécialiste des
murs vous vous intéressez de talent et à
la frontière vous ça vous inquiète ce
qui se passe là qu'est ce que ça annonce
pour vous pas d'abord le mur est en voie
de réalisation il ya dix huit mille de
mur qui a qui viennent d'être érigées
vous savez il peut parfois se passe et
ponctuellement pour militariser la
frontière de l'accord du congrès on a
ponctionné le budget du pentagone
justement à mobiliser vraiment une
partie du budget du pentagone pour
déployer les troupes le refuge de santa
ana non loin de là où vit à alexandre
couture gagnon est en danger et on va
mobiliser des fonds ici et là qui sont
et font discrétionnaire donc le congrès
va pouvoir ralentir le processus peut
être encore plus le ralentir en raison
de son pouvoir d' enquêtes à la chambre
des représentants mais il ya quand même
donc le président va pouvoir continuer à
apprendre et dans le domaine de la
militarisation de la frontière ça peut
se faire sur certains points
indépendamment du congrès par décret
présidentiel parce que le département
durant blaine security a des pouvoirs
exceptionnels qui lui permettent par
exemple de lever un certain nombre de
lois congressional sur l'environnement à
la frontière donc la situation est plus
complexe qu'il n'a permet effectivement
le fait que la chambre des représentants
soit échangé de bord est quand même un
indicateur qu'on va avoir un des points
et contrepoint donc 1,2 me contre pas en
quelque sorte qui va pouvoir exercer une
pression sur le président très bien
merci beaucoup elizabeth
je vous en prie merci alors réactions
moi que je commence à me poser des
questions pour apprendre les nouveaux
membres au sein du parti démocrate qui
ont envoyé les images valent un moment
et à quel point c'est la nouvelle
jeunesse avec une position je pense en
général je connais pas tous les gens qui
ont été élus mais en entendant savoir
que c'est plus progressistes 6 -
centre-droite c'est moins centre c'est
plus centre gauche et il va enfin face à
une direction du parti démocrate qui est
la veille garde de ce type à la vieille
garde au sein de public sénat
le à l'intérieur c'est sûr qu'ils vont
se plier à les électeurs de mme anna
paule aussi c'est tout à fait normal
mais ça n'est pas et qu'au niveau des
commissions au niveau des terrains et
qu'ils vont en faire entre eux voir la
direction du parti démocrate prendre une
position de centre gauche et ça c'est
tout à fait nouveau ce que la partie
depuis plusieurs plusieurs années il
déjà qu'il ya plusieurs candidats
candidate démocrate nouveaux candidats
ce genre contesté déjà de manière même
pas subtil la direction où le leadership
de nancy pelosi de enfin le futur
leadership de nancy pelosi commun comme
chez présidente de la chambre des
représentants dans ses annonces des
divisions et distance ils ont cherché
sur bénéficie de l'appui de bernie
sanders parce que bonnie sérieuse même
si siège pas c'est ici il fait cocasse
avec les démocrates même si ça peut être
pas démocrates ont quand même une
influence ou et puis même s'il décide
d'aller ou de police il va être un
joueur influent
le seul problème il faut se poser comme
question parce que t'es trop tôt de
répondre ce soir
est ce que il n'est pisi d'ensemble du
destiny pourrait dire un parti à la
maison blanche qui est centre gauche
et c'est là qu'on voit vraiment que
c'est moi personnellement je me sens ce
rapport mal à l'aise à obama est élu et
se terrent base la bo qu'un tel un petit
peu plus
une question mais c'est vraiment en ce
moment je pensais trop tôt pour le dire
il ya quand même un mouvement la droite
qui s'est produit aux états unis depuis
longtemps la droite monte d'abord depuis
plusieurs jets la caisse demander si on
va savoir quant au résultat final pour
savoir où sont les états quel rôle a
joué la droite nationaliste blanc oui
j'ai honte
c'est difficile de le dire ce soir mais
parle de budget puisque la chambre des
représentants est très importante à ce
niveau ce niveau là les démocrates ont
tenté de reprocher aux républicains un
accent particulier d'avoir baissé avec
sa réforme fiscale avoir favorisé les
plus riches et de vouloir aller de se
tourner vers le budget de la santé pour
bob ackles en vaut couper la passe qu'il
faut financer notre déficit au lieu de
faire des infrastructures qu'est ce qui
risque de se passer est ce que parce que
les républicains ont dit on va nous
regarder les mafias démocrates avaient
augmenté vous un pont là encore ce qui a
été dit beaucoup dans la campagne et la
bataille budgétaire avec quelque chose
je le répète est visible dès vous avez
des gens en partant deux problèmes deux
prises contre vous le compte ce
gouvernement l'accroissement du déficit
du budget gouvernemental dans le budget
fédéral annuel
mais l'accroissement de l'aide de la
dette publique nationale et vous avez
quand même une loi au congrès parce
qu'il va lui arriver qui limite qui doit
faire que qui doit être autorisée pour
permettre au président de présenter un
budget qui dépasse ces seuils
d'endettement et ce qui est prévu comme
endettement le déjà sous de georges de
bellio bush et obama
on était pas mal craintif mais là on
vient d'augmenter de manière
substantielle d'ici 2040 à peu près le
niveau de déficit dans les deux cas
alors oui ça annonce d'escaladé babou la
porte à d'autres gens dans l'ain
bloomberg par exemple chez démocrate qui
peut affronter
c'est ce que bloom bruxelles une caseta
société maîtrisant plus jeunes très
intéressant parce que moi j'ai vécu une
super niort qu' aucun délégué et je peux
vous dire que c'est un très bon maire et
c'est un vin qui était qui était qui
était progressiste mais qui avait un
côté conservateur il y avait une
responsabilité fiscale mais il est à
progresser surtout le contrôle des armes
c c'est un avant gardiste sur ça
donc moi je voyais je suis je l'avais vu
comme casey ce très intéressant
il peut s'essayer mais je doute qu'il va
pouvoir mobiliser comme tel il ne m'a
quand même faut pas oublier j'étais
d'accord avec avec charles phillips du
site
c'est la prochaine grande crise sociale
mais il est ce qu'on peut pas lui
reprocher de pas avoir l'idée dans les
formes musicales qui avait promis de
livrer c'est la formule républicaine et
il réussit à le faire et c'est pour ça
qu'ils viennent de bénéficier
voici la partie ce soir là est ce que ça
va être la même le même vertige qui va
se donner dans deux ans sur cet amour
mais il risque de ces annonces de tarifs
et sa guerre commerciale commencera pas
du tout ça fait du tort mais à
l'intérieur on est monsieur trudeau
aujourd'hui on ne peut pas l'extrait
l'âme et le sucre doux en entrevue à cnn
aujourd'hui à la journaliste a demandé
faites vous confiance affirme de ute
ross brawn la réponse a été atroce
canadienne et il disait que l'effet de
délibérer pour beaucoup de parler du
logement jour noir mais que l'effet de
ça c'était les amériques et paient leurs
biens beaucoup plus chaud ça va faire
c2a ça peut faire mais il faut faire
attention quand je dis manquera prendre
la majorité à la chambre des
représentants il vous faudra qu'ils
aient une stratégie extrêmement très pro
fini parce qu'il faut pas qu'il fasse
une guerre uniquement puisque la
population voir ça comme une guerre puis
comme un peu une guerre de vengeance et
c'est là ils vont enfin que leurs ânes
lyricson pour fini ça veut dire plus
tout s'attaquer à l'ensemble que ce
qu'ils appellent le pain croûté il va
foirer riel parents les salles de
spectacle mais je suis nouvelle
clientèle et bien d'autres côtés de
contrer les politiques de notre contrôle
c'est pas facile mais qu'est ce que vous
disiez tout à l'heure c'est vous qui le
disent y est c'est à dire il faut
trouver un message qui est constructif
maintenant et pas juste un message
d'opposition ou un message de
destruction peuvent s'attaquer à la
trame sassareu suffira pas en 2020 s'il
assume seul objectif c'est de rallier
tout le monde qui est contre travail
comme ça c'est sûr que ça va être un
élément mais encore faut-il dire une
fois qu'il n'est plus là si cela devait
arriver dans six ans avons fait ce sont
deux en boudant ou dans six ans qu'est
ce qu'on fait après dans notre homme
parce que les voir des grosses dit si ça
convient de mentionner ce déficit qu'est
ce coffret xaris changer le paysage
politique pour tous et non pour le cac
baisse c'était une très bonne question
pige pas su qu'on ne pas répondre ce
soir au mans je pense que y'a quand même
des points de vue de monsieur tram qui
vont soulever monsieur trump mis un
certain populisme et puis des fois il
parlera des idées ou la gauche et la
droite 13 irait peut se rejoignent donc
c'est pour ça que c'est un peu tout en
magasinant sociaux ne s'écarteront deux
semaines où il disait que la vie a
besoin et parce que là on est obnubilé
par te rends pas compte largement cause
de son comportement et sa façon de faire
la façon de parler pas de compassion
quand il ya des entreprises axées plus
qu'elles sont sous menace d'une bombe
la fin de pittsburgh c'est pas de la
compassion c'est mais des idées ont la
possibilité d'aller plus loin
passé c'est plus que ça j'aimerais
emmener qui normalement nos études de
trentenaires en sciences politiques il
est le président est impopulaire
normalement les candidats les candidats
du parti qui se présente cette se
distancer et non pas d'adopter et
d'appuyer presque de d'acheter à dans sa
totalité le message du président il
essaye de se dire ils l'ont fait pour
marquer remarquez ce qui se passe dans
cette élection plus d'1 15 des du
candidat
se sont appuyés sur donald trump son
discours anti migratoire le mur à
l'ailette vous venez de l'évoquer la
pratique réduire par exemple envers la
chine
les les les épithètes envoyé aux
démocrates pour en fait adopter
carrément le programme prom parce qu'ils
redoutent trop de se distancer de dans
notre chambre c'est vous dire
l'effet tram quand même kim est parti si
vous n'êtes pas d'enseignés comme
républicains mais effectivement mais ça
les gens qui l'ont appuyé depuis son lob
que sous certaines de ses promesses à
des règlementations et la défense
fiscale la négociation des ententes ce
plan commence à s'appuyer sur ça mais
quand il est venu pour aller à
pittsburgh
monsieur de canoë messieurs rhein on dit
on n'y va pas parce que la communauté
juive asie on n'a pas à tirer aucun de
nos de nos marais n'est pas question ni
de limite et parce qu'il y avait des
rallyes dans les eaux soir que vous n'a
pas dû les allées pour respecter ce
anciennement les leur coûte le moment
solennel de sa conf à la tension moment
je fus un an
de ce côté les républicains on peut leur
donner toute l'étape spiller des gains
qu'on a connus mais six étapes à des le
public et on a loupé la loi sur les
droits civiques des années ses tapas des
républicains on ne va pas pouvoir réel
car c'est moi je pense qu'il faut penser
qu'il ya des éléments dans ce parti
leurs qui peut émerger et prendre sa
place et aujourd'hui c'est pas un
mauvais résultat pour que certains des
républicains disent s'est cassé je fais
pas la même lecture du tout parce que
moi je trouve que depuis deux ans a
regardé par exemple réflexe d'exemple le
nombre de républicains qui quittent le
navire devrait dire parce qu'il ne
semble plus qu'il soit incapable d'être
financés et d'avoir une identité
distincte des flics le show et
l'opportunité de transformer le parti du
blé
non il est à 20 alors moi je suis en
attente notamment fait ailleurs
j'aimerais ça non je suis nouvelle le
réseau américain nbc prévoit 229 sièges
à la chambre alors la majorité est à 218
il était à 100 95
donc ils ont sont allés au delà de leurs
tracteurs à sièges presque 31 ou 32
sièges de gains sur les changements
démographiques de changement de société
ce populisme qui montre comment les
l'avenir peut les scénarios au fond
qu'on peut envisager pour les plans
vraiment d'abord on a beaucoup parlé de
polarisation je pense que l'on voit deux
hommes comme un facteur polarisant en
même temps il ya une étude qui est sorti
et quelques semaines sur la polarisation
états unis c'est le centre and bird qui
a fait cette étude l'alkyde
effectivement la société américaine elle
est très polarisée mais en 2017 ne l'est
pas plus ce qu'elle était en 2014 alors
déjà ça explique peut-être pourquoi on
obtient ce genre de résultat là malgré
la rhétorique présidentielle malgré
l'agressivité
ça veut dire que les gens autrement dit
ont compris aussi le nouveau schéma dans
lequel on opère et ça ça pue tellement
incidence cette polarisation la part
qu'on est ce pour ça qu'on revient un
peu à ce qu'on faisait tantôt est en
bonne partie issue de ce gentleman de
ring dont on a parlé parce que ça fait
découpage à faire en sorte d'éliminer
les les élus modérés au sein de la
chambre et donc si on arrive par des
décisions à la cour suprême parce qu'il
est de ses causes loi de redécoupage qui
sont devant la cour suprême
si on arrive à faire adopter par les
états de plus en plus de commissions
indépendantes on va peut-être réussir à
renverser un peu les choses donc il ya
cette question démographique qui peut
peut-être changer le paysage
il ya cette jeune génération
effectivement qui poussent mais y aura
des règles il y aura des technicalités à
outrepasser aussi pour qu'on revienne à
un discours peut-être une collaboration
compromis qu'on n'a plus vu depuis
longtemps grâce ayez eu des périodes de
polarisation des années 60 la série 5
gran ça sinon selon évidemment d'autres
allez de vrais cas l'avis de marc
chotteau king est quand même un mec
super u maghrébins en cinq ans a pu
s'évader des émeutes arrivés la
criminalité a là aussi les guerres soul
est quasiment sur les campus avec avec
le vietnam puissance aussi est la raison
qui s'en sont sortis et celle à qui un
peu les quelques piges je suis intéressé
de voir les soutenons sans mentionner
c'est que le centre politique se
tenaient les années 60 aujourd'hui
sympathique ceci moi j'essaie les
extrêmes qui mène ce soit peut-être le
résultat ce soir peut peut-être année
vous êtes moins absolu ce que moi
évidemment puis je jouis est-ce que vous
avez des gens qui ont le dentiste en
tourisme et moi moi je continue à penser
qu'ils repartiraient de plus qu'un c'est
un petit peu dormant qui va se réveiller
je peux me tromper je peux me tromper
mais moi je pense que de partir de
public et un historique c'est quand même
la partie mais kana ces déshérités
je pense qu'à ça c'est la frappe a
scanné des mercis chaque fois que je ne
les vois pas je ne vois pas de
candidature républicaine qui émergent
pour mais s'opposer à dans notre chambre
surtout pas en tout cas dans deux ans
s'il se présente en quarts en dieu je ne
vois c'est l'autre facteur qui est non
seulement pour la gauche mais pour la
droite c'est toute la question du
populisme
le populisme est pas justifiée mondiale
il est partout et les mendiants aurélien
on commence à parler d'un populisme de
gauche imaginer mais brice en deux
points
j'attends alors alors leur avons donné
des résultats
mais avant l'ancien gouverneur du
massachusetts candidat peut pas retirer
jusqu'à l'élection présidentielle de
2012 sénateurs en août à en découdre
c'est également un appel à l'action de
l'action sur des enjeux qui ont été
délaissés finalement
équilibrer le budget réformer nos c'est
sa migration migrants légaux puisse être
accueilli elysées légaux puisse être
muté et aussi résister contre la lourde
mais du fédéral car l'utah sait très
bien ce qui est nécessaire en lutte à
beaucoup mieux que le fédéral
clarens des derniers résultats oui bah
c'est une autre dernière chance de faire
le tour si vous voulez bien ensemble
alors allons-y dans un premier temps il
faut que vous sachiez que tu est close a
été réélu de justesse sénateur du texas
avec 51,6 % des voix beto horreur qu
arrive donc bon deuxième en indiana et
bien c'est aussi le candidat républicain
qui a été élu il défait jo dans nos vies
avec 53 4% des voix
au tennessee maintenant mais là aussi
c'est la républicaine marsha blackburn
la conservatrice affirmé qu'ils
l'emportent avec 55% des voix malgré le
fait qu'on avait mis du côté des
démocrates
un candidat de taille dakota du nord
maintenant et bien aidé à le cam a perdu
son poste chez les démocrates elle sera
remplacé par kevin kremer qui lui aussi
était un candidat de taille pour lui
succéder
elle a été battue à plate couture avec
57 9% des voix en virginie occidentale
est bien là djoman chine retient son
poste il reste sénateur avec tout juste
50 % c'est exactement le même score
qu'il avait fait en 2012
des courses qui ne sont pas toujours
terminé qui reste très serré d'abord
l'arizona où madame mecs à halliche et
les républicains est en avance avec 49,2
% des voix et on surveille aussi la
floride rick scott le gouverneur actuel
qui veut devenir sénateur reste en
avance mais très très serré 50,9 % des
voix contre berne helsinki pourrait
perdre son siège après 18 ans au sénat
pourrait perdre jusqu'à que dépenser des
millions et un milliard est très riche
dépenser des millions d'animaux
merci infiniment alors une belle
harmonie 91 ça y est c'est la conclusion
un mot chacun d'eux mêmes atteintes déjà
pour 2020 regard vers 2
donald qu'est-ce que vous le tremplin
émis pour les démocrates s'ils utilisent
comme il faut pour tous mais j'ai dit je
l'aï mise en place la question de la
chambre des représentants avec de
nouveaux sans religion la maison quelque
chose qu'on a déjà gagné ce qui va
m'intéresser demain sur le taux de
participation des différentes catégories
d'électeurs parce que je pense que ça va
être une bonne indication pour 2020 pour
voir justement qui se mobilisent le
droit des femmes ou ceux qui ont fait la
victoire serait vraiment pas à la fois
comme candidate et au niveau de
l'élection intéresse déjà ça mais
l'histoire internet le vrai gagnant ce
soit au bout de la ligne c'est vraiment
le parti démocrate parce que au bout des
lions plus contre d'une des jambes
le coach franck qui a mis un contour de
champniers port c'est un gain fetwa ses
trois sénateurs de plus leur verre au
niveau du gouvernail mais je pense que
les grenats yannick quelques-uns de plus
qui ont baissé les côtés des mots clés
donc c'est pas une mauvaise soirée de
vos quatre acheté un petit peu déçu de
voir que google ne semble pas toi mais
l'écart est assez important sait déjà
qu'on va revoir sans doute par où il
fait aucun doute mais better work je
pense c'est un peu comme comme jeu c'est
entourant ses premiers monsieur de
bijoux quand tu parles victoire morale
ce même match face à 60 ans c'est une
parole c'est une défaite en ces lieux
saints un peu comme une victoire
monsieur au rwanda tant qu'américain
homme qui parle
entouré de ses proches qui va faire des
concessions
oui et
est-ce que je vais aussi c'est le décor
morale parce que monsieur guillaume ses
claques
il va donner une vedette au niveau de
financement que le passé ces gens là
comme roque et et gims les invités du
financement
donc oui ça peut être un saint paul une
dissidence je pense cette élection
renforce ou concrétise la tendance si je
puis dire non consacré lors des soirées
électorales parce que quand on regarde
défiler à cnn la pente de la lutte ou à
la chambre de représentants vous voyez
que ed clark à égalité pour l'instant
ils projettent évidemment guette dingue
un démocrate mais pour l'instant vous
avez jean 180 18 187 à 11 heures il ya
deux ans ça vous démontre à quel point
l'identité des pareils et complètement
distinctes alors vous avez vraiment le
parti bleu arty des villes le parti de
la population ou la popularité vie et
vous avez le parti de la campagne le
parti rouge si de la ruralité le parti
est là et la californie les bureaux de
vote ferment à 11 heures c'est 50
quelques districts c'est l'état ou de
plus je pense au nombre de 52 depuis de
tirs qui auraient écouté alors des 106
élus donc contre guelma flore et c'est
là dessus qu'on va se laisser parce
qu'on a beaucoup de choses à se réduire
au cours de prochains mois pendant une
semaine c'était formidable de vous avoir
avec nous mesdames et messieurs merci
d'avoir merci leurs amis merci à la
mairie d'avoir suivi avec nous cette
soirée électorale historique enfin
[Musique]
oh